ALLEN ARCHULETA ATKINS BATES
BELL FOR JUST. BRADFORD BY ADAM
CHIANG. SALLY DODD THEY'RE
AWESOME GALGIANI GLAZER
GONZALEZ GRAVE. HERTZBERG HELLO
HUESO TADO. JACKSON JONES LEYVA
MCGUIRE MELENDEZ MITCHELL
MONNING MORE LOCK MORALE.
NIELSEN HAN PORTANTINO ROTH
RUBIO SKINNER STERN. AMBERG I
KOWSKI WIENER WILK. MEMBERS A
QUORUM IS PRESENT WITH THE
MEMBERS AND OUR GUEST BEYOND
THE RAIL AND IN THE GALLERY
PLEASE RISE WE WILL BE LEAD IN
PRAYER THIS MORE BY SENATOR
BRADFORD AFTER WHICH PLEASE
REMAIN STANDING WE WILL BE LED
IN THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO
THE FLAG BY SENATOR UMBERG.
GRACIOUS GOD OF MERCY AND
COMPASSION WE COME BEFORE YOU
THIS DAY IN SORROW AND
HUMILITY. AS WE COME ONCE AGAIN
TO RECALL OUR FAILURE TO LIVE
UP TO THE PROMISE OF LIBERTY
AND JUSTICE FOR ALL. YOU HAVE
STATED BLESSED ARE THE MOURNERS
YET MANY OF US FEEL TO MOURN
FOR THE SENSELESS KILLING OF
PEOPLE OF COLOR IN THIS COUNTRY
HELP US SEEK OUT AN
ACKNOWLEDGED TO REASONS FOR
SLOW PROGRESS MOUNTING
SYSTEMATIC INSTITUTIONAL RACISM
IN THIS COUNTRY. TEACHERS TO
FACE OUR FEARS DISTANCE PRIDE
SHAME WHATEVER CONSCIOUS OR
UNCONSCIOUS MOTIVES THAT HOLD
US BACK FROM ARGUING AN ANTI
RACIST AND CULTURAL SOCIETY
GUIDE OUR CIVIC AND RELIGIOUS
DECISION OLD. BOOK BOB IS THOSE
IN MARGINALIZATION RACISM
BIGOTRY AND PREJUDICE BECAUSE
IN YOUR EYES WERE ALL CREATED
EQUAL CONTINUE TO REMIND US
THAT DIVERSITY IS THE HALLMARK
OF YOUR CREATION. THE
MANIFESTATION OF YOUR PRESENCE
AND IT SPARKS OF YOUR DIVINE
LIFE ON EARTH WE ASK THESE
THINGS IN YOUR NAME AMEN. YEAH
JOIN ME. YEAH ALL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. MEMBERS TWO DAYS AGO
THE LEGISLATURE HELD A CEREMONY
ON THE CAPITOL STEPS. THAT'S
CEREMONY HONORED GEORGE GEORGE
FLOYD BRIANNA TAYLOR SEVEN
CLARK SANDRA BLAND AND ALL
THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN NEEDLESSLY
KILLED BECAUSE OF THE
SYSTEMATIC RACISM THAT IS
PLAYED THIS NATION FOR FOUR
HUNDRED YEARS. TODAY THE SENATE
WILL EXTEND THAT HONOR BY
JOINING IN A MOMENT OF SILENCE
FOR GEORGE FLUORIDE AND ALL OF
THOSE KILLED. RIGHT NOW
VIOLENCE TO PAY OUR RESPECTS TO
THE LOST AND TO COMMIT
OURSELVES NEVER ENDING FIGHT
FOR JUSTICE AND EQUALITY.
THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. MEMBERS WERE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO PRIVILEGES
OF THE FLOOR. THERE ARE NONE.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL
BE DEEMED READ. MESSAGES FROM
THE ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEEMED
READ. REPORTS OF COMMITTEES
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS ADOPTED. MOTIONS
RESOLUTIONS. AND NOTICES MADAM
PRO TEM. YEAH AB. MEMBERS I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUBMIT A LETTER TO THE JOURNAL
REGARDING DISAPPOINTMENT
PROCESS AND JUST A VERY QUICKLY
LET ME SAY WITHOUT CONSULTATION
WITH THE VICE CHAIR MY VICE
CHAIR OF RULES FROM SANTA
CLARITA THIS HAS TO DO WITH
GOVERNMENT GOVERNOR'S OINTMENTS
AND JUST SPECIFICALLY- UNDER
NORMAL CIRCUMSTANCES A RULES
COMMITTEE WOULD REQUEST
CERTAIN. GOVERNOR BEFORE OUR
COMMITTEE HOWEVER IN ORDER TO
COMPETE- COMPLETE THE NECESSARY
VETTING PROCESS AND MATTER
MATTER PROTEOMIC WE CAN WAIT A
MINUTE MAKE SURE THAT THE MY-
ARE THE HERE. AND WITH. SOME
BUT. I CAN GO TO A DIFFERENT
MIKE OR IS THAT BETTER. PART OF
THE. OKAY. MADAM PRO TEN MOST
TRY THAT AGAIN BETTER MIKE. Q.
THE MAN PRESIDENT I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CAN CONSENT TO SUBMIT
A LETTER TO THE JOURNAL
REGARDING THE APPOINTMENTS
PROCESS. AS CHAIR OF RULES AND
ALONG WITH MY VICE CHAIR OF THE
MEMBER FROM SANTA CLARITA- WE
HAVE HAD CONVERSATIONS AND WANT
TO SUBMIT THIS LETTER TO THE
JOURNAL UNDER MY SIGNATURE. I
DO TO THE APPOINTMENT PROCESS
OF REFORM. UNDER NORMAL
CIRCUMSTANCES ARE RULES
COMMITTEE WOULD REQUEST A
CERTAIN INNER SELF APPOINTMENT
HERE BEFORE THE MEDI HOWEVER IN
ORDER TO COMPLETE THE NECESSARY
VETTING PROCESS UNDER OUR
TRUNCATED SLATED ADELINE. THE
COMMITTEE DETERMINED. I'M NOT.
HE THAT DECISION TO MODIFY
MIDEAST TYPICAL PROBLEM PROCESS
IN WAY FIFTY CENTS A NEW
PRESIDENT THEREFORE THE LETTER
TO THE JOURNAL WE WILL. FARM
ALL OTHER STEPS- ROBUST VETTING
PROCESS IN EACH APPOINTEE WILL
STILL BE SUBJECT TO APPROVAL
BEFORE THE FULL SENATE. I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
ME ABOUT THIS DECISION PLEASE
DON'T HESITATE TO CONTACT ME IF
YOU HAVE ISSUES AND I WILL
CONTINUE UNDER OUR PROSPECTS TO
BE. VERY UNDER COMMUTER WITH
THE CHAIR OF THE RULES
COMMITTEE SO THAT THERE IS
CONSENSUS ON THE MEMBERS- BE
ARE RECOMMENDED FOR APPOINTMENT
BEFORE A RULES COMMITTEE AND I
WILL. HAVE A LITTLE MORE OF IT.
ENDING OF WHAT THIS LETTER IS
NOW IN TERMS OF YOUR SUPPORT TO
SUBMIT IT TO THE GENERAL THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT. THANK YOU
SENATOR. YOU HAVE YOUR MY CAP.
OKAY SENATOR MITCHELL. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MADAM PRESIDENT
TO UNDER MOST OF THE
RESOLUTIONS I'D LIKE TO BUY
THEM EIGHT TWENTY THREE A. B.
ELEVEN EIGHTY FIVE MCCARTY.
FROM THE ENACT THE FILE TO
THIRD READING. THE SECOND
READING. I'M ASKING TO MOVE
ITEM EIGHT TWENTY THREE AB
ELEVEN EIGHTY FIVE MCCARTY FROM
THE AN ACTIVE FILE TO SECOND
READING. THAT SHOULD BE THE
ORDER THANK YOU. SENATOR ARGUE
LETTER. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS I RISE TO
MOVE AB ONE ZERO ZERO SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES SAWYER
FROM AN ACTIVE FOR PURPOSE OF
AMENDMENT THANK YOU. SUCH WILL
BE THE ORDER. SENATOR JACKSON'S.
THANK YOU UNDER MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS ARE WOULD YOU
PLEASE REMOVE OF SB ELEVEN
FORTY SIX FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR TO THE THIRD READING
CALENDAR. SO ORDERED. SENATOR
SKINNER. NO IT'S JUST THE TWO.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER MOTIONS AT
THIS TIME. WE'RE STILL UNDER
MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THE FOLLOWING
RESOLUTIONS WILL BE PLACED ON
TODAY'S SPECIAL CONSENT
CALENDAR ITEM ONE TWENTY S. C.
R. EIGHTY SIX. WITHOUT
OBJECTION THE SENATE JOURNALS
FOR MARCH SEVENTEENTH THROUGH
THE ELEVENTH TWENTY TWENTY WILL
BE APPROVED AS CORRECTED BY THE
MINUTE CLERK. ARE THERE ANY
FURTHER MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS FOR
NOTICES. SINGMAN. MEMBERS WILL
MOVE ON TO CONSIDERATION OF THE
DAILY FILE. MOVING ON TO
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENTS SENATOR
WELK. ITEM NUMBER ONE. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS
FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE IS A
CONFIRMATION OF TOKYO MICHIGAN
AS DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT
OF TRANSPORTATION PRIOR TO THIS
APPOINTMENT MR- BUT- WILL BE
SHAKEN WAS DEPUTY COMMISSIONER
FOR ENVIRONMENTAL AND PLANNING
AT THE TENNESSEE DEPARTMENT
TRANSPORTATION HE WAS APPROVED
BUT THOSE COMMITTEE ON MAY
TWENTY SEVENTH I RESPECTFULLY
ASK. DR IS IT IS. ARE DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. SENATOR BRADFORD YES
I CHIU SUPPORT THE POINT POINT
OF MR SHAKING AS- CALTRANS OUR
DEPARTMENT TRANSPORTATION TO
STATE AND WANT TO NOTE THAT HE
IS THE FIRST AFRICAN AMERICAN
TO EVER HOLD THIS POSITION AND
IN LIGHT OF ALL THE CHALLENGE
THAT WE HAVE WITH RACE I THINK
IT'S COMMENDABLE TIME SPACE IN
LIGHT OF WHAT WE'RE DOING WITH
THIS ONE. WITH THE BOND SPECTER
GENERAL AND MAKING SURE WOMEN
MINORITIES HAVE OPPORTUNITY
CONTRACTS SO I'M EXCITED ABOUT
THIS APPOINTMENT. SENATOR BELL.
OUR MEMBERS AS THE CHAIR OF THE
SENATE TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE
I WHOLEHEARTEDLY ENDORSES
APPOINTMENT I THINK YOUR ART
CALTRANS DIRECTOR AND I HOPE HE
STAYS A LONG TIME WILL- DO
WONDERS IN IMPLEMENTING SB ONE
AND- COMPLETING OUR PROJECTS ON
TIME AND ON BUDGET. ARJUN AYE
VOTE ON. PRESIDENT I ALSO RISE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS- APPOINTEE
OR NOMINATE AN I DO JUST WANT
TO SAY IN A CALTRANS. IS AN
AGENCY THAT- IT NEEDS A LOT OF
HELP A LOT OF MODERN BEEN
REPORT. IF THIS IS AN AGENCY
THAT AT TIMES WE HAVE- JOKINGLY
A NOT SO JOKINGLY REFERRED TO
AS THE DEPARTMENT O HIGH IS.
BECAUSE IT IS SO FOCUSED ON
HIGHWAYS AND NOT ON OTHER FORMS
OF TRANSPORTATION LIKE. OWNING
OR BY JANE WHERE THE NEEDS A
PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION. THERE IS
AND WE SEE INVEST. BILLION OR
IS WITH THE WAY CAL AND-
INTERACTS IN A SOMETIMES A BAD.
THE WAY WITH LOCAL CAN. AND TO.
RESET HOW TO BE STATE. SAFER
FOR PEOPLE TO WAIT FOR THE BUS
OR TO WHERE TO BUY IT'S BEEN A
SHOE PROBLEM FOR MANY MANY
YEARS AND PEOPLE ARE GETTING
INJURED AT NINE AS A- THIS. HI
T. FIVE SHE FIVE COMES A
BACKGROUND THAT IS MUCH MORE
TUNES- TO BEING IN THE TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY TRANSPORTATION
WORLD AND UNDERSTAND THAT NOT
EVERYONE GET ROUND BY DRIVING
AND WE NEED TO MAKE STATE ALL
THERE'S INCLUDE. WHO ARE WE-
SHIN SO I AM CRITICS ABOUT THIS
OF AND LOOK TO A NEW DAY FOR
CAL. AND YET IS THERE ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THE SIDE OF. MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN.
FIVE ARCHULETA OR AYE ATKINS
FIVE BATES FIVE WELL. BY FORGES
FIVE BRADFORD I COME BY ADAM
FIVE CAN. I DALLY FIVE DODD.
FIVE THEY'RE AWESOME NINE FIVE
GALGIANI. FIVE GLAZER I
GONZALEZ I GROWTH. I HERTZBERG
I HILL. I HUESO. HI TADO.
JACKSON FIVE JONES I LEYVA.
FIVE MCGUIRE AYE MELENDEZ I
MITCHELL FIVE MORNING. I MORE
LOCK. ZERO I. NIELSEN I HAN.
FIVE PORTANTINO. I ROTH. I
RUBIO. I SKINNER I STERN I
NUMBER I LIKE HOW SCHEME. I WE-
I WILK HI THIS CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS TADO. MORE LOCK HI.
FIVE THIRTY NINE NO ZERO THE
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED ITEM
NUMBER TWO SENATOR WELL. MADAM
PRESIDENT FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO
SO CONFIRMATION OF MERRY BILL
BATCHELOR AS PRESIDENT THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION.
ARE YOU DISAPPOINTED MS BASHER
SURFER SIX YEARS AS SECRETARY
FOR THE GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS
EIGHT THREE. BY THE SENATE
RULES COMMITTEE TWENTY. THE
SPECS WE ASK FOR YOUR AYE.
SENATE HERTZBERG. MEMBERS I
DON'T TO RECALL VERY OFTEN THAT
I HAVE STOOD IN FAVOR OF.
APPOINTMENTS AND X. MAYBE. OR
THIRD TIME IN MANY. BUT I DO SO
THAT YOUR BECAUSE I WORKED WITH
HER THROUGH MANY
ADMINISTRATIONS MANY DIFFERENT
PARTIES MANY DIFF PERMITS AND
AS I SAID IN THE ONE OF THE
COMMITTEES WHICH TESTIFIED SHE
IS ONE OF THE- I AM. SHE'S
GIVEN HE SIX SAW PROBLEMS AND
CERTAIN WITH REGARD TO THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION SHE
HAS A TOLL OR WE ALL KNOW THAT
FROM OUR EXPERIENCE. AND SO I
JUST STRONGLY. OINTMENT I THINK
THAT SHE WILL MAKE A
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT AND I WAS
VERY EXCITED TO SEE WHICH SHE
FIRST GOT APPOINTED AND I'M
EXCITED TO DATE STAMP IN
SUPPORT OF HER APPOINTMENT
THANK YOU MA'AM. SENATOR WIENER.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
EVENTFUL DAY FOR APPOINTMENTS I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF THE
CONFIRMATION OF PRESIDENT DR TO
CALIFORNIA FORTY TWO COMMISSION.
IS AN EXTRA CON AND QUALIFIED-
CANADA I CONCUR WITH MY
COLLEAGUES SAYS MY COLLEAGUE
FROM- LOS ANGELES. AND SO I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
APPOINTMENT. I HELP I DO WANT
TO EXPRESS WE ARE NOW OPEN
BURNING CONFIRM THE PRESIDENT
OF THE- UTILITY COMMISSION. I
WANT. SYRIA TIONS ON THE
CURRENCY OF AFFAIRS AT THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION THE CITY YOU SEE BY
EXCEPTIONALLY SMART TALENTED
COMMISSIONERS NOT JUST ABOUT
HER BUT THE- WAIT SMART AND
TALENTED. BY ISRAEL'S CONTINUE
TO SUFFER FROM SEVERE
INSTITUTIONAL BIAS AND A NURSE.
THAT IS DAMAGING CALIFORNIA THE
CITY CITY HAS TAKING A
DISTURBINGLY LENIENT APPROACH
ARE PARTICULARLY TOWARDS P.
JEANNIE FOR MANY MANY YEARS AND
CONTINUES TO DO SO- APPROVING-
OVER. EIGHT THREE SAYS COMPANY
THAT HAS FAILED. AND READ
PERMANENTLY SUSPENDING A TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR FINE
RELATING TO THE IMMENSE
DEVASTATION THIS COMPANY
BECAUSE THE. THAT KIND OF
APPROACH. UNLIKE PGA ARE UNLIKE
THE CBC'S APPROACH OCCASION A
THE CITY HAS TAKEN AN
EXCEPTIONALLY HARSH APPROACH
THIS IS THE MEDIAN STRIP
AGGREGATORS CCA'S ARE GOVERNED
BY ELECTED OFFICIALS WHO ARE
FULLY ACCOUNT. I HAVE A SPARE
AND SEE. BUT NEVERTHELESS
FIFTIES HAS TAKEN A HOSPITAL
AND DRACONIAN APPROACH TOWARD
CCA'S. FIVE FOR EXAMPLE JUST
RECENTLY IT LITERALLY TODAY
ACTUALLY THE CPC IS CONSIDERING
A LITTLE BIT OF PASSED WILL
LIKELY READ IN THE REMOVAL OF
PCA'S ABILITY TO YOU OR IN
STORE TO CREATE VIRTUAL POWER
PLANTS. SEVEN IS YES. SEVERAL
LATE ARE WE LIVING EX A SICK
WITH APPROACH AND SIX FIGURES
B. AS CONSIDERING UNDERLINING
UP. IN ADDITION HE HAS
CONSISTENTLY SHOWN HOSTILITY
TOWARDS DISTRIBUTED ENERGY
RESOURCES OUR DVRS LIKE SOLAR
AND STE. AND TWENTY EIGHTEEN
BUDGET BETTER OVERWHELMINGLY
PASSED SB SEVEN HUNDRED TO RE
AUTHORIZE AND RE FASHION THE
ESTá PROGRAM TO EXPAND THE
STORAGE IN CALIFORNIA. EVEREST
IF YOU DESPITE THE OVERWHELMING
BY PART. IN THIS LEGISLATURE
HAS BEEN ASLEEP UNDER MY AND
DAMAGING THIS PROGRAM AND
RECENTLY DEDICATED A LARGE
MAJORITY OF THE FINES THAT ARE
SUPPOSED TO INCREASE STORAGE.
CALIFORNIA TO IT HI. HOWEVER
FEE I GUESS THAT MIGHT NOT
BEING TAPPED INTO THE CPC HAS A
OF A DEBILITATED ASTOR PRO
MINING. IT THE CLEAR INTENT OF
THIS LEGISLATURE. BUY TOYS I
MAKE THIS REMARKS NOT TO
CRITICIZE PRESIDENT DR- I'M A
BIG ADMIRER OF HER. BUT TO NOTE
THE DE INSTITUTION AND- THE
BIAS. AND INERTIA IS HARMING
CALIFORNIA'S ENERGY POLICY I
HOPE TE PRESIDENT VOUCHER AND
THE OTHER WONDERFUL
COMMISSIONERS ON THIS AGENCY
CAN TURN THIS. THANK YOU DOLLY.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT TO
MEMBERS I TO RISE- TO SUPPORT A
PRESIDENT THAT BACHELOR I. I'VE
BEEN SOMEBODY WHO'S BEEN VERY
CRITICAL OF THE P. YOU SEE
ACTUALLY HAD A BILL THIS YEAR
TO DISBAND BC BUT DO WHAT WE
DID OPPORTUNITY TO HEAR THAT.
BUT I WILL SHARE WITH YOU I
THINK AS MANY YOU THAT SAID ON
THE ENERGY COMMITTEE. AT OUR
HEARING LAST WEEK. YOU KNOW
THAT SHE IS MOVING IN A
DIRECTION THAT I THINK IS
POSITIVE FOR THE P. YOU SEE SO
I WILL BE SUPPORTING HER TODAY.
IN ANTICIPATION OF FURTHER
PROGRESS THE P. YOU SEE HAS.
MANY AND- WHAT WE JUST HEARD
FROM MY COLLEAGUE- FROM THE BAY
AREA. AND THEIR ISSUES THAT
NEED TO ADDRESS. WE NEED TO
HAVE ONLY JEFF. SEVENTY INPUT.
IN TO THE RIGHT THING FOR THE-
THIS IS A- SO I WAS SUPPORTING
HER TODAY AND LET. TO THAT OPEN
DOOR TO BRING THE PEACE. BACK
WHERE IT NEEDS TO BE THANK YOU.
SENATOR HILL. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES- IN IN
SUPPORT THIS A NOMINATION THE
END OF FOR INFORMATION TODAY
AND FOR THE VERY SAME THINGS
THAT TO A GOOD AND FROM SAN
FRANCISCO DELAYED ABOUT PROBLEM
IN THE CHURCH IS IT THE THANK
YOU TO COMMISSION A BIG REASONS
WHY I AM. HER POSITION TODAY
AND CONFIRMATION BECAUSE SHE
BRINGS THAT WHAT I'VE SEEN IN
IS SO NECESSARY IN THAT IT TOO
AND THAT IS IT. IT WILL IN AND
SANITIZE AND CLEAN UP WHAT HAS
BEEN HISTORICALLY A VERY SLOW
MOVING OPERATION. AND
REGULATORY BODY. IT HAS BEEN
HESITANT IT HAS BEEN FILLED
RIFE WITH POLITICAL INFLUENCE
AND POLITICAL APPOINTMENTS.
THAT DID VIRTUALLY NOTHING.
OVER THE PAST IN PROTECTING THE
INTERESTS OF RATE PAYERS THE
SAFETY OF CALIFORNIANS. AND THE
INSTITUTIONS THAT WE ALL VALUE.
SO THIS IS A REAL BREATH OF
FRESH AIR FROM SOMEONE WHO I
BELIEVE HAS THE ABILITY AND HAS
SHOWN THAT EXHIBITED THAT
ELSEWHERE IN THE- WORKINGS OF
GOT. SHE CAN BRING TO THAT
INSTITUTION THE RESILIENCY THE
SPEED THE REFORM. THAT WE'VE
BEEN LOOKING FOR MANY YEARS SO
I SUPPORT THIS CONFIRMATION AND
LOOK FORWARD TO THE MANY YEARS
OF HER LEADERSHIP THANK YOU.
SENATOR DODD. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT OUGHT I WOULD JUST
LIKE TO ECHO IN THE INTEREST OF
TIME THE VERY ELOQUENT DOT COM
AND FROM MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN
MATTEO I SEE IT'S ABOUT
PRESIDENT PC. SENATOR BAIT.
VERY GOOD ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE OVER
CENTER JACKSON YES I- ALSO WANT
TO APPLAUD THIS AND I'VE WORKED
WITH A BILL THE BACHELOR. HAD
THE HONOR PRIVILEGE OF
INTERVIEWING HER FOR HER LAST
POSITION WHEN I SERVED ON THE
RULES COMMITTEE- I THINK SHE
WAS PROBABLY- IF I'M NOT
MISTAKEN THE FIRST ONE. TO THE
POINT THAT OUT. WE ARE VERY
BLESSED TO HAVE SOMEONE OF HER
CONFIDENCE OF HER COMMITMENT AS
MY GOOD COLLEAGUE FROM LOS
ANGELES POINTED OUT SHE IS.
COOLEY A LEADER. IN THE RIGHT
PLACE AT THE RIGHT TIME TO DEAL
WITH ALL THE ISSUES THAT HAVE
BEEN ARTICULATED HERE ARE AND I
THINK WE ARE. A BLESSED THAT
SHE WILLING. CONTINUE PUBLIC.
AND TAKE ON VERY CHALLENGING.
BUT I THINK WE WILL ALL BE VERY
PLEASED TO WORK WITH HER. AS
SHE COLLABORATED INDIVIDUAL SHE
THINK WE'LL TAKE DIRECTION. OF
THE FRONT INTO POLICY IT WILL
LIGHT OUT. WHICH IN DEALING
ISSUE. WITH THE- AND I AM VERY
HONORED TO SEE A POINT TO THE
POSITION. I THINK MATCH.
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION TO USING THE
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL NO OKAY.
I'M SECRETARY CALDERON. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA I ATKINS I BATES I
FELL FIVE GORGEOUS. I BRADFORD
I HAVE A ADAM. I CAN HI DOLLY I
DODD. BUY THEIR AWESOME. FIVE
GALGIANI FIVE GLAZER FIVE
GONZALEZ FIVE GROWTH. I
HERTZBERG I HILL HI WITH SO I-
TADO. JACKSON I JONES I LEYVA.
FIVE MCGUIRE I MELENDEZ I
MITCHELL. I MONEY. FIVE MORE
LOCK I MORRELL. FIVE NIELSEN. I
PAN. I PORTANTINO. HI ROTH. I
RUBIO. HI SKINNER. HI STERN. HI
NUMBER HI I LIKE HOW SKI. I
WIENER. I WILK HI. THE
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED I
THIRTY NINE KNOWS ZERO. MEMBERS
THAT CONCLUDES OUR GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENTS FOR TODAY WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO SENATE
THIRD READING. THE FIRST ITEM
IS ITEM NUMBER FIFTY. SENATOR
MORLOCK ARE YOU PREPARED. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL NINE NINETY EIGHT BY
SENATOR MORLOCK AN ACT RELATING
TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT. SENATOR
MOORLACH THE FLOOR IS YOURS
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AN
HONOR TO BE THE FIRST OWNER OF
A BILL TODAY AFTER THREE MONTHS.
CALLING SERVICE. IN THE
TREASURER OF ORANGE COUNTY ON-
MARCH SEVENTEENTH NINETEEN
NINETY FIVE I HAD THE PRIVILEGE
OF BEING ON THE MANAGEMENT TEAM
AT- PREPARE THE PLANET JUST TO
GET THE COUNTY OUT OF. JEFF
FROM. THE FEDERAL COURT ROOM.
CHECK THE FOLLOWING TWELVE
YEARS I WORKED ON A LOT OF
BILLS TO IMPROVE THE INVESTMENT
CODE FOR THE STATE CALIFORNIA A
LOT OF FUN DOING THAT AND WAS
SUCCESSFUL EFFORT SO SB NINE
NINE EIGHT KIND OF BRINGS YOU
BACK TO THOSE DAYS WHERE I NOW
DO IN THE BILL. PROVE THE- CAL.
CUT DURING THIS BILL FOR THE
CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL TREASURES
ASSOCIATION AND IT KIND OF
CARRIES THREE INTERESTING
OPPORTUNITIES BUT THEY ARE
SIMPLE SAY THE NECESSARY. HE'S
AN EXCHANGE MISSION FOR MONEY
MARKET FUNDS UNDER RULE TO A
SEVEN ALLOWS. MANY MORE THE 1%
OF THEIR PORTFOLIO ON. THIS
BILL ONLY SET UP 240% CERTAIN-
PORTFOLIOS IT ALSO MAKES A
DIVERSIFICATION IMPROVEMENT BUT
BY THE IT AT A CREEK POLL BUT
TENSION. PROVISIONS BUT HE TO
INVEST NEGATIVE INTEREST
INSTRUMENTS ON JUNE SECOND CNBC
REPORTED THAT ST LOUIS FEDERAL
ECONOMIST E. NGUYEN ANNOUNCED
THAT POLICY MAKERS WILL NEED TO
CONSIDER NEGATIVE INTEREST
RATES IN GETTING THE UNITED
STATES A BACK TO HELP. THIS HAS
OCCURRED IN JAPAN. IS AN
APPROPRIATE TROUBLE
CALIFORNIA'S INVESTMENT CO DOES
NOT CURRENTLY ACCOMMODATE THIS
INVESTMENT SO WE NEED TO- TAKEN
REMEDY THE SILENCE COLLEAGUES
SB NINE NINE EIGHT. LEAVE SHOWS
FOR PAPERS THING THAT IT. I WE
SHOULD BE PREPARED I RISK ASK
FOR A VOTE ON SB NINE NINE
EIGHT. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. SEEING NONE. IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO USING THE
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON THIS
ITEM. AND THE MEASURE PASSES
THIRTY NOT ICE THIRTY NINE
KNOWS ZERO. MOVING ON MEMBERS
TO ITEM NUMBER FIFTY THREE.
SENATOR BRADFORD ARE YOU
PREPARED MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL ELEVEN FIFTY
SEVEN BY SENATOR BRADFORD AN
ACT RELATING TO TENDENCY
SENATOR BRADFORD THE FLOORS.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT SB
ELEVEN FIFTY SEVEN WOULD BE THE
FIRST IN THE NATION AT THIS
BILL IF PASSED REQUIRE.
LANDLORDS OF SUBSTANCE TO DIS
MULTI FAMILY RESIDENTIAL
PROPERTIES TO OFFER YOUR
TENANTS THE OPTION OF HAVING
THEIR RENT PAYMENTS REPORTED TO
A MAJOR CREDIT PEARL. BY FOCUS.
SUBSIDIZE IN THE BILL ALERT TO
THOSE TENANTS LIKELY TO RECEIVE
THE GREATEST BENEFIT STEP. OR
IN THEIR CREDIT SCORE. WE ALL
KNOW THE FACTS OF A NEGATIVE
CREDIT SCORE AND THE
CONSEQUENCES THAT IT HAS ON
PEOPLE WHO FAIL TO PAY RENT OR
ANY OTHER BILL TIME THERE'S NO
REASON WHY WARNER RAPPERS. WHO
REGULARLY A- THEIR RENT SHOULD
RECEIVE POSITIVE IMPACTS ON
THEIR CREDIT SCORE FOR DOING SO
PARTICULARLY NOW DO THE COLBERT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC A LOT OF
CALIFORNIANS ARE SUFFERING
ECONOMICALLY. THIS BILL COULD
HELP YOU SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF
THOSE STRUGGLING CALIFORNIA'S
BY GIVING THEM A WAY TO IMPROVE
THEIR CARE CREDIT SCORE. ON AN
PROSPERITY NOW AND IS SUPPORTED
BY SERVICE. THE GROUPS
INCLUDING WESTERN CENTER WITH
LONG PARK PROPERTY- WE HAVE
NOT. REACHED CONSENSUS WITH THE
ROTORS FOR- PARDON SO SHUSHAN
BUT WE'RE CLOSE TO THE
NEGOTIATIONS ARE GOING AS WE
SPEAK AND- HI INCOME COMMITTEE.
MOVING THIS FORWARD IF IT GETS
OFF THE FLOOR TODAY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
HERTZBERG. MADAM PRESIDENT THIS
IS A REALLY IMPORTANT BILL. ONE
OF THE GREAT CHALLENGES THEY
WERE FACING WITH RESPECT TO THE
ON BANKS AND UNDER BANKED.
TRYING TO GET THEM INTO THE
SYSTEM THAT IS COMPLETELY
DESIGNED ABOUT CREDIT CARDS AND
LOANS WITH RESPECT CREDIT
RATING. WE HAVE STRUCTURAL
PROBLEM WITH RESPECT TO GETTING
PEOPLE CREDIT AND HERE PEOPLE
EVERY OTHER TO THEIR UTILITY
BILL OR PAYING THE RIGHT EDGE.
SHOULD BE IN THE TOP WHETHER
THERE WERE THE. THIS IS A
DOESN'T LOOK LIKE A BIG BILL
BUT IT'S ONE OF THOSE
INSTITUTIONAL ARCHITECTURAL
PROBLEM WE HAVE THE
DISADVANTAGES PEOPLE. IN THE
WAY THE JUSTICE ON FAIR THIS
UNBANKED AND UNDER BANKED
PROBLEM IS HUGE IN CALIFORNIA.
AND YOU TALK TO YOU SEE THAT
REMAIN BANK HE START IN INDIA
AND AFRICA. WOMEN THE SMALL
BONES THEY BASICALLY SOCIAL
COMMITTEE IS ENOUGH. TO PAY
STUFF BACK IN THEY DON'T HAVE
THE TRADITIONAL KINDS OF IN
DISH TO IN THE WORLD. THERE ARE
SO MANY. WE DID HER WEATHER.
CREDIT FOR THE AND THE SYSTEM
IS STAFF BUT- THE UNBANKED AND
UNDER BANKED THIS IS A HUGE
PIECE IT DOESN'T GET BUT I.
WITH THIS MEASURE. STEP AGAINST
THE KIND OF INSTITUTIONAL BIAS
THE COURAGE TO PEOPLE WHO DON'T
LIVE WITH CREDIT CARDS AND ALL
THE OTHER KINDS OF THINGS THAT
ARE ON LEAVE IMPORTANT.
INVALUABLE AND TO BE CHARGED
THE KIND OF INTEREST RATES FOR
THE NIGHT LOANS THAT HAPPENED
THESE THINGS THEIR CREDIT IS
NOT PROPERLY BEACON I STAND
STRONG SUPPORTER THIS MAY.
SENATOR YES. NUMBER CAN I SPEAK
WITH THIS OFF WORD. I BELIEVE
WE'VE BEEN ASKED TO KEEP THE
MONEY FEDERAL. OKAY AND YOUR-
ALLOWED INTO IT IT WE HEAR IT
BETTER OUR THANK YOU FOR
EVERYBODY. I APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR'S INTENTION HERE AND I
THINK DURING A JUDICIARY
APPEARED REMOTELY. SOME
QUESTIONS AND I THINK IT KIND
OF GOES TO THE HEART OF WHAT
CREDIT IS. OUR CREDIT SYSTEM IN
THE UNITED STATES IS PREMISED
ON PERSONAL RELIABILITY. AND
ONE OF THE CONCERNS THAT I HAD
HERE IS THAT WE ARE
INCORPORATING INTO THE CALCULUS
OF PERSONAL RELIABILITY BASED
ON PAST PERFORMANCE IN OTHER
EXTERNALITIES. ON WHAT. IN THIS
I HAVE SOME MERIT THAT THERE
ARE MANY INSTANCES THERE'S NOT
ENOUGH OPPORTUNITY FOR PEOPLE
IN NEED TO. WHERE THE NECESSARY
CREDIT FOR UPWARD MOBILITY. THE
CONCERN WITH THIS IS THAT WE
COULD BE ARTIFICIALLY INFLATING
THE CREDIT PROCESS ON FAIRLY
WHAT I MEAN BY UNFAIRLY IS
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A SEGMENT
OF THE VISUALS FOR HAVING THEIR
RENT CHECK. FOR BY WHETHER YOU
NEED TO EAD ANY THERE SO
SERVICE. WHAT DO NOT MISS ALL
OF OUR ACTION EIGHT WERE MORE
ONLY BECAUSE OF THEY'RE NOT
THIS- ON ALL TO NEEDS TO HAVE
DISCRETIONARY RENT CHECKS I
CAN'T. PROCESS DONE THE AUTHORS
PUT IN THIS PLEDGES. SO I WOULD
THINK THAT THIS WOULD BE MADE
MUCH MORE. COMPREHENSIVE AND
MORE FLEXIBLE IF THIS WERE
APPLIED TO ALL RENTERS THAT
SHOULD A RENTER WHETHER THEY'RE
SECTION EIGHT- FOR WHETHER THE
HE THE- RENT. BE ABLE TO REACH
OUT TO THE LANDLORD IN. LORD
ALL BOARDS THE REPORTING IT. I
THAT WOULD BE A EQUITABLE TO
LOOK AFTER BOTH THE INTEREST
THOSE WHO KNEW IT IS MOBILITY.
WORDS WHO ARE THE THIRD ONE
ENOUGH. MORE PAY THEIR BILLS
TIME SO I THE UNDER THIS
CURRENT FOR IT'S A BETTER I
UNDERSTAND THE PURPOSE BUT IT
IT LITERALLY. DOES NOT KING
POOR IN THERE THAT'S A
SIGNIFICANT SEGMENT OF THE
RENTAL RENTAL POPULATION HELLO
FOR. SENATOR BREAUX. SHARE THAT
BETTER THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I
THINK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD BECAUSE I
THINK THAT IF PEOPLE DO PAY THE
RENT ON TIME THAT IT. VALIDATE
THEIR- BUT I ALSO HOLE HOT.
PERCENT AGREE WITH MY COLLEAGUE
FROM FRESNO THAT THIS BILL ONLY
LIMITS TO THOSE THAT HAVE
GOVERNMENT FUNDING TO PAY THEIR
RENT AND NOT THE WORKING POOR
OR INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE. APRIL
STORE SCORE. TV BUYING THEIR
OWN. IF WE CAN I WOULD PULL HER
SUPPORTED THAT WOULD ALLOW ALL
INDIVIDUALS YOU KNOW WE'VE GOT
OUT OF THIS CODE CRISIS AND
SAYS BASICALLY WERE ALL. ALL OF.
WE'LL TELL YOU FOR ALL THE WAY
FOR THAT GO OUT WORK EVERY DAY
AND PROVIDE FOR THEIR FAMILIES
ON MY INCOME PEOPLE TO USE THAT.
TO A STAFF CREDIT SCORE AS WELL
AS A HIGHER CREDIT- TO SEE IF
THEY WERE ABLE TO PAY THEIR
BILLS ON TIME AND SO I WHOLE
HEARTEDLY MY COLLEAGUES PRESS I
DO THINK A- TO A LOT HELLO AND
TO ABLE TO. HELP THERE WERE
THEY PAID. HIS SO THAT. ALSO
ARM SO INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE
WITH THE WORKING POOR IN ANY
AND ALL MEANS SOME PEOPLE'S
RIGHT CAN BE A VERY HIGH
INSTANTLY. INSTILL BE TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE THE STREET TO
PURCHASE A HOME. AND SO. ALL
CAL. TO CURRENT RENT PAYMENTS
AND THE PAYMENTS BEING MADE ON
TIME AND SO LIKE I SAID I
APPLAUD THE BILL IN THE THOUGHT
PROCESS BEHIND BILL I JUST
THINK IT SHOULD BE GOOD FOR
CAL. IS FOR ALL ALL. LIKE I
MIGHT. SENATOR RICK OWSKI.
MADAM PRESIDENT I RISE SINCE OF
THIS BILL YOU KNOW I'VE HAD THE
MANY PIECES OF LEGISLATION TO
TRY TO ADDRESS THE COLOR DEBT
THE CHECK WE HAVE FOR THIS CALL.
WHEN IT. UNDER UNDER. THIS
FIRST IN THE NAY. PROGRAM THAT
WE ARE WE'RE FOCUSED ON PEOPLE
THAT LIVE IN INNER ASSISTANT
HOUSING. BUT I CAN SAY ANYTHING
LANDLORDS NOW CAN VOLUNTEER
REPORT THE ACTIVITIES GOING.
THE RED TO THE CURRENT AGENCY
ENOUGH TOPS THE PRIVATE IN FROM
THAT I WOULDN'T. EVERYONE FROM
TO DO IT BUT WHEN PEOPLE
RECEIVE GOV ASSISTANCE IN ORDER
TO HOUSE PEOPLE THIS IS THE
FIRST STEP THE FIRST IN THE
NATION PEOPLE LOOK AT THIS AND
TRY IS WE LEARN MORE ABOUT THE
COLOR OF DEBT AND I WOULD.
EFFECTS P. AND PORTING AGE.
HOPEFULLY AND CRIMINALLY I'LL
FOR TO WORK WITH THE- MY
COLLEAGUES ON THE OTHER SIDE I
HAVE SO IDEA. IN THIS AREA AND
YEAR THE WOULD. BE SOMETHING BE.
ON THE EXEMPTIONS IT AND HOW WE
DEAL WITH PEOPLE THAT ARE. TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF BY PRESS LENDING
BUT THIS IS. AGAIN THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WE SHOULD BE IT.
EMBRACE AND BE PROUD OF FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND I URGE
AN AYE VOTE. THERE ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION THAT SENATOR
ARCHULETA. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT IS IT THE SPIRIT OF
CALIFORNIA EQUALITY IS THE
SPIRIT OF CALIFORNIA BRINGING
PEOPLE TOGETHER THE SPIRIT OF
HEALING WELL WHO ARE WE TALKING
ABOUT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THOSE
ARE STRUGGLING EVERY SINGLE DAY
AND WHAT THEY HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY BECOME PART OF THE
MAINSTREAM. IS IF YOU LOOK AT
IT. JOINT IN. FEE SO DOES NOT
WANT TO PART THEY DON'T BECAUSE
THEY DON'T WISH TO IF THEY IT'S
A TEN DOLLARS ADMINISTRATIVE
FEE SO IT GIVES AN OPTION BUT
LOOK AT THE DOORS IT'S GONNA
OPEN UP THAT THERE BE GOING TO
BE ABLE TO ESTABLISH LINE OF
CREDIT TO ONE DAY MAYBE BY OUR
OUR MAYBE ONE DAY ESTABLISH.
THE LADY. STEP SHOW I THINK WE
HAVE LOOK AT THE- AS WE LOOK AT
THINGS THAT TWENTY TWENTY. AS
WE LOOK AT THINGS NOW LOOK AT
THINGS THAT ARE HAPPENING
AROUND US THROUGHOUT THE NATION
AND WE WILL BE THE FIRST. TO
SAY LET'S TAKE THE STEP FORWARD
AND QUALITY. ALL THE WAY ACROSS
THE BOARD AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU. THERE'S NO
FURTHER ACTION OR DEBATE.
SENATOR BRADFORD YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
ANALYSTS THINK MY COLLEAGUES
BOTH IN SUPPORT OR- HE'S GOING
COLLEAGUES FRESNO WELL AS BACK
BAKERSFIELD RIGHT WE WERE LOVE
THINK. EVERYONE AND PROCESS IN
FOR WE FIELD FOLKS WHO ARE
BEING AND HAVING THE RENT
SUBSIDIZED GREETED ME. MANY
TIMES FOLKS WERE LIVING. HOW
THEIR WORK POOR TO AND THEY'RE
IN SOME HOUSING BE THEY DO NOT
HAVE CREDIT AND IT'S BEEN A-
SIDE OF DEBT THAT IS BEING
GENERATION BECAUSE THEY HAVE
NEVER BEEN ABLE TO STAY SPREAD
SO WE WANT. AS WE IT ON BY I'M
WE WILL INCLUDE YOUR B. AS WE
IT AS. THE BOND. THE TENANT
HOUSE FALLEN TO YOUR DO THIS.
TO THAT TO AS WELL TO A IN
PROGRAM BUT AT THE SAME TIME WE
STAY. WERE CONCERNED OR
ADJUSTED CONCERNING MAKE SURE
THAT FOLKS HAVE BEEN AND A SO
DE THAT ARE A BANK OFF TO A LEG
IN THE- SOCIETY AND STOP REDIT.
AND ONE DAY HOPEFULLY BECOME.
AS WE- ARE DIRECTLY BROUGH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SECRETARY TO CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I ARCHULETA I ATKINS I
BATES. BELL I FOR JUST.
BRADFORD I HAVE A I CHIANG.
DALLY DOT I THERE ARE SO. FIVE
GALGIANI I GLAZER I GONZALEZ I
GROWTH. I HERTZBERG I HILL I
HUESO. I TADA. JACKSON I JONES.
LEYVA I MCGUIRE AYE MELENDEZ.
MITCHELL I MONNING I MORE LOCK.
ZERO NO NIELSEN. NO HAN I
PORTANTINO. I ROTH I RUBIO. I
SKINNER. I STERN. I UMBERG I
WHITE HOUSE SKI. I WIENER I
WILK. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. FAITH FOR JUST NO
CHIANG. DALLY. TADO JONES.
MELENDEZ. WARLOCK NO. WILK.
FIVE TWENTY NINE KNOWS FOR THE
MEASURE PASSES. MOVING ON TO
AYE NUMBER FIFTY FOUR. CENTRE
BELL MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL EIGHT SIXTY
BY SENATOR VAL AND ACTUALLY BE
TO FOSTER YOUTH CENTER BELL THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS- DO YOU KNOW THAT. IN
TERMS OF FINANCIAL AID
APPLICATIONS THAT ONLY 11% OF
ELIGIBLE FOSTER USE ACTUALLY
GET A CAL GRANT OUT- GRANT
ELIGIBLE FOR FURTHER HIGHER
EDUCATION OR THE ONLY 40%
CALIFORNIA'S FOSTER YOU. THEIR
ELIGIBLE FOR THE FEDERAL PELL
GRANT ACTION TO GET THE GET THE
PELL GRANTS AND I THINK OUR
RECORD IS PRETTY MISERABLE IN
TERMS OF. THE FINANCIAL FOR. IT
OR DO THE BILL SB EIGHT SIX.
EIGHT CLARIFY THE ROLE OF THE
FOSTER YOU COORDINATING PROGRAM
TO INCLUDE COURTING EFFORTS TO
SUPPORT- THE COMPLETE GEN-
FEDERAL LONG DIFFICULT FORM
THAT WE ALL FEEL OUT. FOR OUR
OUR STUDENTS TO POLISH. THIS
CALL THE FAST FIVE. AND THIS
FAST FOR A NEEDS TO BE FILLED
OUT SO THEY CAN BECOME ELIGIBLE.
FOR THESE GRANTS SAID THEY'RE
ELIGIBLE FOR. AND THIS WOULD-
CLARIFY THE ROLE THE FOSTER YOU
CORDONING PROGRAM. TO HELP THE
FOSTER YOU TO FILL OUT THESE
FORMS AND HELP THEM GET THE
GRANTS THERE ARE DESERVING. IT
WOULD ALSO ADD TO THE. PROGRAM
THAT THE COMPLETION RATE FOR
FILLING OUT THE FORMS AS PART
OF THEIR BI ANNUAL REPORTING SO
WE CAN HAVE A MEASUREMENT OF
HOW SUCCESSFUL. KIND OF
PERFORMANCE WERE HAVING FOR
FOSTER YOU- GETTING THEM INTO
COLLEGE- THIS IS A SIMPLE
SOLUTION THAT COULD WORK FOR A
SIMPLE PROBLEM THAT WE NEED TO
SOLVE. AND MY EXPERIENCE WITH
FOSTER YOUTH AND MENTORING THEM
IS THEY NEED HELP. I HAVE A
HAVE YOU EVER TRIED TO HELP ON-
GET INTO COLLEGE IT'S NOT EASY.
IT'S NOT IT'S VERY DIFFICULT
FOR THEM TO DO IT TOO- DO IT ON
THEIR OWN SO LET'S PASS THIS
BILL ARJUN AYE VOTE ON IT. SIR
ANY. DEBATE ON THE SIDE OF.
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO USING THE
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. THING NINE
THIRTY NINE I. ZERO KNOWS THE
MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS ARE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER
FIFTY SIX SENATOR MCGUIRE.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL OF FOURTEEN FORTY
ONE BY SENATOR MCGUIRE AN ACT
RELATING TO TELECOMMUNICATIONS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH- MAN OF HERS
IN IN IN GOOD MORNING MEMBERS
AS WE'VE ALL BECOME TOO
FAMILIAR WITH CITIES AND
COUNTIES ARE GOING TO HAVE TO
FACE REALLY CHALLENGING BUDGET
SOME WOULD SAY DISASTERS. IN
THE COMING FEW YEARS DUE TO THE
FINANCIAL IMPACT OF CORONAVIRUS
AND IT'S CLEAR THAT THE STATE
TAKES ACTION TO ENSURE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS MAINTAIN EVERYWHERE
YOUR SAID THERE SO. FORTY ONE
DOES YES. REMOVING THE SIGN
HELLO GOVERNMENT THE BILL TO
GET. UTILITY USER TAX IS. FROM
THE RETAIL SALES TO PREPAY WHY
TELL. PRODUCTS AND SERVICE SUCH
AS THOSE PHONES YOU CAN PURPOSE
WITH BE LOADED MINUTES. AT
MEMBERS THERE ARE A HIGH ONE.
AND COUNTIES TO COLOR. THE VIEW
T. ON PREPAID WHY WHICH HAVE
RECEIVED. TWO FOUR MILLION A
NEW. SINCE THE WAS ENACTED THE
MEASURE ONLY A TO LOCAL IMPOSE
VOTER. UTILITIES ARE TAX NOT
STATE SURCHARGE PROVISIONS OF
EIGHT NINETEEN SEVENTEEN NEVER.
BY THE COURTS WITHOUT SP FOUR
WE WANT COUNTY SURE CAN BE IS.
DO STEVEN. FACE FORCE LOCALS TO
MAKE EVEN MORE CHALLENGING
DECISIONS THAT CRITICAL SERVICE.
WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO FOR
MEMBER. BAIT TO VOTE COMMITTEE
IN IT BORDER. THE WIRELESS HI
EIGHT ON THIS ITEM. SEEING NONE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL MADAM
SECRETARY. ALLEN I ARCHULETA I
ATKINS I BATES. I FELL HI
GORGEOUS FIVE BRADFORD. I HAVE
I ADAM I CAN. FIVE DALLY I DON.
I THEY'RE AWESOME I CALLED
GALGIANI I GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ.
I GROW. I HERTZBERG I HILL I
HUESO I TADA. JACKSON I JONES I
LEYVA. I MCGUIRE AYE MELINDA'S
I MITCHELL. I MONNING I WARLOCK.
FIVE MORALE. FIVE NIELSEN. I
CAN FIVE PORTANTINO I ROTH. I
RUBIO I SKINNER. I STERN HI
NUMBER NINE I LIKE CASTING I
WIENER I WILK I. FIVE THIRTY
NINE NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS ARE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
ITEM NUMBER FIFTY NINE SENATOR
WHITE HOUSE KEY MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL EIGHT
NINETY EIGHT BY SENATOR Y.
KOWSKI AND ACTUALLY INTO CIVIL
ACTIONS. THE FLOOR IS YOURS
MISTER A QUOTE FROM MANTA
PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES THE
GREATEST HURDLES FAMILIES FACE
AND CONTEMPLATING WHETHER TO
PURSUE POST SECONDARY EDUCATION
IS THE SKYROS FAT GUY ROCKETING
COSTS OF ATTENDING COLLEGE
DESPITE THESE TROUBLING. TRENDS
MANY CALIFORNIANS CONTINUE TO
SEE THE VALUE OF POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION FOR THEIR CHILDREN
SAVINGS PLAN SUCH AS THE
SCHOLARSHIP. FIVE TWENTY NINE
ACCOUNT PROVIDE FOR YOU PLEASE
OF ALL INCOME LEVELS WITH A
DIVERSE SET OF BEST MAN WINS
WHEN YOU CALL FIGHT HIRED.
UNLIKE RETIRED PLAN WITH TO
FOUR OKAY OR A- GOVERNMENT RITA
PLAN SCHOLAR SHIRT ARE AFFORD
PROTECT FROM. CLAIMS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA SO WHAT WE
TELL LITTLE GEORGIA LITTLE
EMILY THAT THEY'VE GOT MONEY TO
GO TO COLLEGE IT'S ACTUALLY ME
AND DADDY'S MONEY. AND THE
BECAUSE THEY'RE THE ACCOUNT.
ACCOUNT HOLDER IS WHEN THEY'RE
FACED WITH JUDGE THE CREDITOR
THE ABILITY TO **** THE MONEY
IN THE ACCOUNT TO SATISFY A
JUDGMENT PRESENTLY CALIFORNIA'S
TWENTY TWO STATES WITHOUT STATE
BAR CREDITOR PROTECTION FOR.
ALL SB IN EIGHT SPAN LIST OF
JUDGMENT EXAM UNDER CAL BANG
LAW THANK FAMILY SAVINGS IN THE
SCHOLAR SHARE COUNT IT MAKES
SOME OTHER TECHNICAL CHANGES TO
UPDATING THE COST OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENTS AND STATE
TREASURER'S THE SPONSOR AND I
AND I VOTE. SENATOR BRIDGES.
MADAM PRESIDENT MAY- POSE A
QUESTION TO THE AUTHOR THREE OF.
SENATOR I CAN BE WOULD YOU TAKE
A QUESTION YES THANK YOU. HI
THIS IS A VERY GOOD IDEA I
LIKED IT WHEN I FIRST HEARD IT-
IN JUDICIARY I THINK THERE.
THERE WERE ONLY A COUPLE OF
FOLLOW UP QUESTIONS. IS THAT
THIS IS LIMITED TO THE
CALIFORNIA- US- EDUCATION
PROGRAM WHAT ABOUT PRIVATE
ENTITIES IN CALIFORNIA OR EVEN
LOCATE ELSEWHERE THAT WOULD
ALLOW FOR A SAVINGS ACCOUNT.
SENATOR RICK OWSKI THROUGH
CHAIR WILL OF THE GENTLEMAN
FROM FRESNO MAKES A GOOD POINT
CONSIDER LIKE NINETY OF THESE
COLLEGE HERE PROGRAMS.
UNFORTUNATELY THE ONLY ONE
THAT'S ADMINISTERED BY THAT THE
TREASURE HI IS THE CHAIR FIVE
TWENTY NINE AND WHILE THESE
OTHER PLANS I'LL I'LL TELL. IN
IN THEM IS NO ABILITY SENATOR
CONTROL THE OTHER STATES FIVE
TWENTY NINE PLANS OR THE
ACTIVITIES OF THESE OTHER
CULTURE. OWNERS THE INTO YOUR
IS TO ENSURE COLLEGE FIVE
TWENTY NINE OFFER SPECIAL. THE
CALIFORNIANS SO THAT'S WHAT WE
THIS STEP THE EXEMPTION. AND AS
OF WHAT BOB. WHAT THE MAXIMUM A
HOW CAN CAN. TOWARD A CHAU THAT.
AND CAN I COME FROM A VARIETY
OF DIFFERENT SOURCES TO SURPASS
AMOUNT IN THE AGGREGATE. I
SHOULD KNOW THAT IT'S UP WORDS
TO. THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS I THINK AND I APOLOGIZE
FOR NOT HAVING THAT ON MY
FINGER TIPS- ENDICOTT YES YOU
CAN COME FROM A VARIETY OF
DIFFERENT SOURCES AGAIN AS LONG
AS ARE CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS
BECAUSE HE WOULD BE TAKING
BENEFIT EXEMPTION FOR OTHER
STATE THAT'S THEIR OWN.
EXEMPTION SUPPLY I THINK WANT
INCLUDE ID THE PROTECTIONS
BANKRUPTCY IN THE FOR TWO
INTENDED. HOUSEHOLD WERE THEIR
HOME OUR THIS CAN BE THE
MARGINALITY. I THINK THE HAVING
THE PROTECTIO STORAGE ASIAN
THESE IN THE BE OUT OF
TRADITIONAL DOMAIN OF CRITTER.
I THINK ULTIMATELY WILL BE VERY
HELPFUL AND I'LL BE SUPPORT
THIS THANK YOU. GOOD ANY OTHER
DISCUSSION OR TO ON THE SIDE OF.
SENATOR MARLA THANK YOU MADAM.
RESIDENT I JUST HAVEN'T WITH
HIS BILL BE IT IS ONLY A TO.
SECTION FIVE TWENTY NINE PLANTS
THAT ARE PROVIDED BY THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. I BELIEVE IN A
IN A NO BETTER NO WORSE
APPROACH TO LEGISLATION SHOULD
BE PICKING WINNERS AND LOSERS-
IF THE PRIVATE SECTOR'S GOT BY
TRAINING PLANS A NEED TO BE
PROTECTED FOR THE SAME VERY
REASONS BECAUSE JOB IN GENERAL
AND- THE REST WERE RELYING ON
THAT MONEY. H. H. BY CROSS WORD
SO THAT I I'M VERY INCOME WITH
THE BEING SELECTIVE IN THIS
NATURE THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. RIGHT IS THERE ANY
FOR THE DISCUSSION. SINGMAN
CENTRE ACOSTA YOU MAY CLOSE
WILL MADAM CHAIR I CAN MAKE A
COMMITMENTMY ENTHUSIASM FOR
EXPANDING THE EXEMPTIONS THAT
PROTECT- A CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS
FROM WHETHER THEIR FROM THEIR
HOUSE HOMESTEAD EXEMPTION OR
FROM DIFFERENT VARIABLES
CONTINUE TO LOOK HE SAID THE
OTHER PLANS I'VE I'VE HAD SOME
TROUBLE WITH SOME OTHER BILLS
TO SPEND EXEMPTION I'M TRYING
TO. THE NEW BALL ACCOUNTS TO
GET. I AM BUT FOR YOU. TO WORK
MY COLLEAGUES THE TO EVER EXT.
SO THAT WE PROTECT CALIFORNIA
FROM ACROSS AND WITH THAT I
WOULD URGE AND I. MADAM
SECRETARY CALL ROLL. ALAN HI
ARCHULETA I AT. I BATES I WELL
I GORGEOUS I BRADFORD. I HAVE I
ADAM I CHIANG I DALY. DODD I
RAZA I GALGIANI I GLAZER I
GONZALEZ HI GROWTH. I HERTZBERG
HI HILL. HI WAY SOON OR I TADO.
JACKSON I JONES. LEYVA HI
MCGUIRE I MELENDEZ. MITCHELL I
MORNING I MORE LOCK NO BROWN.
AROUND. NO NIELSEN I PAN HI
PORTANTINO. I ROTH. HI RUBIO. I
SKINNER. I STERN. HI NUMBER
NINE I WHITE HOUSE SKI ON I
WIENER. I WILK HI PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT. DALLY I TADO. JONES
MELENDEZ. FIVE THIRTY FIVE
KNOWS TO THE MEASURE PASSES
MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER SIXTY
SENATOR GLACIER WAS PREPARED
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL
THIRTEEN FORTY NINE BY SENATOR
GLAZER AN ACT RELATING TO
TAXATION UNDER GLAZER THE FLOOR
IS YOURS THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS. STATE
LAW CAPS THE TOTAL RATE OF
TAXES OF ANY COUNTY IN
TRANSPORTATION THAT 2% ON THE
LEGISLATURE IN THEIR WISDOM IS
A LOT SEVERAL CITIES COUNTIES
IN COUNTY TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITIES TO IMPOSE TAXES
ABOVE THAT. LEVEL OF THAT'S OF
COURSE WHAT THIS BILL WOULD DO
WOULD ALLOW CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY. TO RAISE COUNTY SALES
TAXES ABOVE THE CAP. AS MANY
FOLKS KNOW OUR CITIES AND
COUNTIES ACROSS THE STATE ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR PROVIDING
CONSTITUENTS WITH VERY
IMPORTANT SUPPORTIVE SERVICES
POLICE AND FIRE HOMELESS PUBLIC
HEALTH AMONG MANY OTHERS THE
SERVICES ARE PARTICULARLY
IMPORTANT DURING TIMES OF
CRISIS. I DO TO COVERT NOT KEEN
CITIES IN CONTRA COSTA ARE
ESTIMATING LOSSES OF REVENUE IN
THE MILLIONS THE COUNTY
ESTIMATES A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR REDUCTION. YET THE NEED
FOR PUBLIC SERVICES CONTINUES
TO RISE IN THE AFTERMATH THIS
PANDEMIC. THIS BILL WOULD GIVE
THEM THE OPTION AND I STRESS
THE OPTION. OF AFTER ASSESSING
ALL THEIR FUNDING NEEDS. TO
HAVE THE PIN THE ABILITY TO GO
TO THEIR VOTERS AND MAKE THE
CASE FOR TAXES ABOUT THE CAP
THAT'S CURRENTLY IN PLACE. WITH
PASSED SIMILAR MEASURES AS I
MENTIONED OTHER COUNTIES AND
WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. SINGMAN
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
OUR CHILDREN ARE HI ATKINS I
BATES. BELL BY FOR JUST.
BRADFORD FIVE BY ADAM I CHIANG.
NO DALLY NO DODD. I AWESOME. I
GALGIANI I GLAZER I GONZALEZ. I
GROWTH NO HERTZBERG I HILL. I
HUESO. I TADO. JACKSON I JONES
NO LEYVA I MCGUIRE. I MELINDA'S
NO MITCHELL. I MONNING. I MORE
LOCK NO MORAL. NO NIELSEN. NO
HAN. FIVE PORTANTINO I ROTH. I
RUBIO. I SKINNER. HI STERN I
NUMBER. WHITE HOUSE SKI HI
WIENER. I WILL. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. BATES NO FORGES.
NO TADO. I'M BURKE. WILK NO.
FIVE TWENTY SEVEN KNOWS ELEVEN
THE MEASURE PASSES. I GUESS.
MEMBERS WERE READY TO MOVE ON
TO ITEM NUMBER SIXTY ONE BUT I
A WANT TO ASK YOU TO PLEASE-
STAY IN YOUR SEATS IF YOU CAN
IT WE'RE TRYING TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE CAN SEE WHO TO SPEAK
AND WE CAN KEEP TRACK OF WHERE
EVERYONE IS. SENATOR TO LEAD
AND HE LOOKS LIKE HE'S READY
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL NINE OH FIVE BY
SENATOR ARCHULETA AN ACT
RELATING TO PRIVACY CENTER ARE
TO LET IN THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT. AND
MEMBERS I RISE TO PRESENT
SENATE BILL NINE OH FIVE
BACKGROUND CHECKS SECURITY AT.
CALIFORNIA ALLOWS ORGANIZATIONS
TO REQUEST ALL OF AN
APPLICANT'S RECORDS OF
CONVICTIONS FROM THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF JOB. IF THE
APPLICANT WOULD HAVE SUPERVISED
DISCIPLINARY POWER OVER MINOR
OR ANOTHER IN THEIR CARE. THIS
MEASURE IS PRUDENT STEP IN
ENSURING THE SAFETY OF THE
MINERS OR OTHER BROUGH
INDIVIDUALS. HOWEVER THESE
REQUESTS CAN BE EXPLOITED TO
DIVULGE THE LOCATION OF
UNDOCUMENTED INDIVIDUALS THAT
ARE APPLYING TO VOLUNTEER IN
THEIR COMMUNITIES. THE FEAR OF
THIS PERSONAL INFORMATION BEING
TAKEN HAS CREATED A CHILLING
EFFECT ON THE BUT VOLUNTEER
EFFORTS OF ORGANIZATIONS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
INDIVIDUALS ARE AFRAID OF
VOLUNTEERING A CONTRIBUTING IN
THEIR COMMUNITIES FOR FEAR OF
THEIR PRIVACY BE IN BREACH BY
FEDERAL ENTITIES. DURINGTHE
CALL BUT NINETEEN CRISIS WE
NEED VOLUNTEERS MORE THAN EVER
THROUGHOUT OUR STATE.
ESPECIALLY NOW PEOPLE SHOULD
NOT BE HELD BACK TO BURST- TO
PROCURE FOR CONTRIBUTING AND
OBTAINING THE ABILITY TO
CONTRIBUTE TO THE COMMUNITY AND
BEING PART OF THE COMMUNITY. SB
NINE OH FIVE PROTECTS THE
PRIVACY OF CALIFORNIANS BY NO
LONGER REQUIRING A RESIDENCE
ADDRESS ON THE BACKGROUND CHECK.
BY NOT REQUIRED RESIDENTS
ADDRESS ON THE BACKGROUND
CHECKS WE CAN PROVIDE
ASSURANCES TO INDIVIDUALS THAT
THEY CAN VOLUNTEER IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES WITHOUT RISKING AND
COMPROMISE COMPROMISING THE
SAFETY AND SECURITY THEMSELVES
OR THEIR LOVED ONES. THERE'S NO
NO OPPOSITION BILL HAD RECEIVED
NO NO VOTE FOR THESE REASONS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MATTER PRESS.
THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. SEEING NONE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA HI ATKINS I BATES.
WELL I FOR JUST. BRADFORD I
HAVE A ADAM FIVE CHIANG HI
DOLLY. DODD HI TORONTO. I
GALGIANI FIVE GLAZER I GONZALEZ
HI GROWTH. HERTZBERG AYE HILL
FIVE HUESO. I TADA. JACKSON I
JONES NO LEYVA I MCGUIRE. I
MELINDA'S NO MITCHELL. FIVE
MONNING FIVE WARLOCK. ZERO NO
NIELSEN. I PAN I PORTANTINO I
ROTH. FIVE RUBIO. I SKINNER. I
STERN I NUMBER NINE HI MY CAO
SKI. I WIENER. I WILK. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. BATES
FOR JUST. DALLY GROWTH NO TADO.
MORE LOCK. WILK. FIVE THIRTY
FOUR NO I MEAN EXCUSE ME FIVE
THIRTY DOLLARS FOR THE MEASURE
PASSES. I'M GOING TO MOVE ON TO
ITEM NUMBER SIXTY SIX SENATOR
BRADFORD ARE YOU PREPARED.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL TWELVE FORTY FOUR
BY SENATOR BRADFORD AND
ACTUALLY NEED TO CANNABIS
FLOORS YOUR SENATOR BREAK MADAM
PRESIDENT SB TWELVE FORTY FOUR
IS THE STREET FOR CONSUMER
PROTECTION ISSUE ALL AGREE THAT
WHETHER. IT'S THE SYMBOL OR
RENT XIN ADULT USE WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE CONSUMERS
ARE FOR IT IS NO SECRET THAT AT
CANNABIS TELLS OF INCREASED
DURING THIS CALL BUT IN RIGHT.
IN THIS BEARD BUT THEY DO NOT
QUALIFY FOR ANY OF THE FEDERAL
PROTECTION SUCH AS PPP. SO I
THINK IT'S VITALLY IMPORTANT
THAT WE MAKE SURE THAT THE
PRODUCTS THAT ARE BEING SOLD
ARE SAFE- PROTECTS NOT ONLY
CONSUMERS BUT- THOSE LEGITIMATE
BUSINESSES AS WELL IT ALLOWS.
REGULATORS IN AGENCIES TO- COME
IN AND TEST THE PRODUCT UNDER
THE STATE LEVELS IT'S A FREE
FOR MEASURE NURSE FOR CLASS FOR
DRIVE A. ALLEN YEAH. SENATOR
SENATOR DOLLAR. THANK YOU MADAM
MEMBERS OF I HAD JUST ONE RISE
AND AS A OF THIS BILL AS
SOMEBODY WHO RAISES SEED AND
PRODUCES IT AND IT'S REGULATED
BY THE CALIFORNIA PART OF FOOD
ACT SO THAT THE CONSUMER KNOWS.
WHAT THEY'RE GETTING IN IN THE
BACK YOU SEE THAT I'M SELLING
THEM LIKEWISE I THINK THIS IS A
GOOD TO LET THE CONSUMERS- AND
HAVING A BILL BILL A TEST THE
NEXT NO IT'S IN THOSE POSH BY.
THE AUTHOR BUT I THINK IT'S A
GREAT WOULD ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
IS THERE ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. SINGMAN CENTER
BRADFORD YOU MAY CLOSE. FROM
BEAVER AND I'LL USE THAT AS MY
CLOTHES AS RIVAL. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ACTION THIS THIS BILL IS OUT
FOR A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION. SAYING
NINE THIRTY NINE I KNOW ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS ARE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER
SIXTY SEVEN SENATOR DR SO ARE
YOU PREPARED SHE IS PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL TWELVE NINETY BY
SENATOR DORADO AN ACTUAL
LEADING TO JUVENILES SENATOR DR
SO THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK
YOU THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. SB
TWELVE NINETY WILL MAKE ALL
PREVIOUSLY ASSESSED JUVENILE
AND CRIMINAL JUSTICE FEES
AGAINST YOUNG PEOPLE TWENTY ONE
AND UNDER UNENFORCEABLE AND ON
COLLECTIBLE AND IT WILL VACATE
ALL COURT JUDGMENTS THE BILL
THE GREEN MEN'S AND OTHER
INSTRUMENTS IMPOSING SUCH.
BETTER INCLUDED TEND. US RITESH
COP AN ELECTRONIC MONITORING
MON. COLLECTING FEES FROM
SYSTEM INVOLVED YOUTH AND THEIR
IS REGRESS. ON A ON BURDEN ON
PEOPLE TRYING TO TURN THEIR
LIVES AROUND RESEARCH SHOWS HAS
SHOWN THAT THESE FEES WILL FALL
HARDEST LOW IN COMBAT AND
KNEELEDLITTLE NET REVENUE IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN. THROUGH THE
LEADERSHIP OF MY COLLEAGUE
SENATOR MITCHELL THE
LEGISLATURE STOP ALLOWING
COUNTIES TO CHARGE YOUTH AND
FAMILIES NEW. INDUSTRY OF. THEY
DID A YOUNG PERSONS OF ALL IN
THE JUVENILE AND CRIMINAL
SYSTEM. TODAY LOW INCOME
FAMILIES ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY
REPRESENTED IN JOB LOST LOST
DUE TO COVERT NINETEEN AND THEY
HAVE BEEN HIT THE HARDEST BY
THE ECONOMIC CRISIS. YOU'D
EFFORTS TO COLLECT FEASIBLE ALL
TAKE THE HARDSHIP EXPERIENCED
BY THESE FAMILIES WORSE WHICH
IS WHY PERMANENT DEBT RELIEF IS
IMPORTANT SO IMPORTANT. THE
LEGISLATOR DID NOT STOP
COUNTIES FROM COLLECTING FEES
PRIOR TO THE ENACTMENT OF THE
CURRENT LAW. THIS MEASURE WILL
STOP THAT ACTORS. I KNOW
COUNTIES OFFICE AS MUCH MONEY I
COLLECT AT THEM SO. THEN THE
FEES THAT RECEIVE WHICH IS WHY
DATE FORTY COUNTIES HAVE
VOLUNTARY ENDED COLLECT IN SAN
DIEGO. LOS AND RIVERSIDE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU I WILL.
SENATOR MITCHELL. THANK YOU
VERY MADAM ALL EYES INS OF
THREE RAZA F. TWELVE NINE AND
APPRECIATE HER WHEN OF THE WORK
LAW AND I DID BUT OUR EFFORTS
FELL SHORT QUITE FRANKLY ARE
BILL DID NOT COME THROUGH AT
CHARGES ITS STOCK CHART FROM A
POINT IN FOR. SOMEONE MISSION
AT THE STATE. UNDER MY THE
READER THAT THE CASE GOAL OF
ARGUE JUSTICE SYSTEM AND THIS
FOR BURDEN FAMILIES IF POVERTY
AS WELL FROM OF COLOR. I THEM
IN SUPPORT THIS BILL LUNCH THAT
CALLS ON THAT KERR ALLOW OVER
TWENTY COUNTY FROM COLLECTING
MORE THAN A HUNDRED THIRTY SIX
DOLLARS AN OUNCE WE DO NOT BE.
FROM QUE MALL VOTE FOR. AT THE
GET TO IN TO. HOW THESE FEES
OKAY WE NEED OF THESE JUVENILES
WITH THEIR FAMILIES FOR THOSE
REASONS I SENSE OF THE BILL. IT
THERE ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS ON
THE SIDE OF. SEEING NONE. THREE
MADAM TAKE A SEPARATE PLEASE
THE ROLL. SENATOR DRAWS A WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK ME I WILL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA I ATKINS I FACE I
FELL HI GORGEOUS. BRADFORD I
HAVE ITEM I CHIANG. I DOLLY.
DODD FIVE THERE ARE SO. HI
GALGIANI I GLAZER I GONZALEZ I
GROWTH. HERTZBERG I HILL FIVE
WITH SO I TANTO. JACKSON I
JONES. LEYVA I MCGUIRE. I
MELINDA'S NO MITCHELL I MONEY I
WARLOCK MORRELL. NO NIELSEN I
PAN I PORTANTINO. I ROTH. I
RUBIO. I SKINNER. I STERN I
NUMBER I WHITE HOUSE SKI. I
WIENER I WILL HI PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. FOR JUST.
DALLY GROWTH TADA. JONES MORE
LOCK. FIVE THIRTY TWO KNOWS TO
THE MEASURE PASSES MOVING ON TO
ITEM NUMBER SEVENTY TWO SENATOR
BRADFORD. MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL
FOURTEEN FORTY EIGHT BY SENATOR
BRADFORD AND ACTUALLY NEED TO
FIRE PREVENTION. ENTER BRADFORD
THE FLOORS YEARS THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT SB FOURTEEN
FORTY EIGHT HOPE THIS ADDRESS-
WHAT IS TRULY A PROBLEM HERE IN
CALIFORNIA DANGERS WALL FIRES
PC AS STATED AS WELL AS OUR
WALL FIRE- SAFETY ADVISORY
BOARD THAT. THEY'RE UNDER STAFF
IN ANY EXPERIENCE WORK FOR
SKILL UTILITY WORKERS TO HELP.
WITH WALL FIRE MITIGATION THIS
BILL HELPS TO ADDRESS THAT BY
REACHING OUT TO OUR VACATION
CORES IN OUR CONSERVATION CREWS
WORK ON THE FIRE LINES. AND
HELPING ADDRESS THIS PROBLEM
MANY TIMES THESE INDIVIDUALS
ARE THE UTILIZED AND EVEN
CANNOT FIND JOBS WOULD BE HIRED
BY THE ITALY TO DO SO WORK THIS
BILL HELPS TO FACILITATE THAT.
BRINGS EQUITY TO THE STATE
NEEDED AND FRANKLY AS FOR FIVE
VOTE. IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS I. SENATE
TURN. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AS
ONE TO COMMIT THE AUTHOR FOR
HIS WORK ON THIS AND THIS IS AT
CRITICAL OF THE WILDFIRE WERE
IS BEING GOING ON FOR THE LAST
FEW MONTHS AND REALLY POINT OUT
THAT IN THIS LEGISLATION IS NOT
JUST IMPORTANT EQUITY OR FIRE
STRATEGY WOULD REALLY IS A PATH
TO RECOVERY AND MAKE DEVELOP A
STRATEGY. THE WE KNOW WE NEED
BOB WE KNOW WE PEOPLE WITH
SKILL SET ON THE SIDEWALK SO
LET'S GET TO WORK RESPECT YES.
CENTER NIELSEN. PRESS LAYS IN
DENTAL THE SENATE I THANK MY
CALL FROM LET'S SAY FOR
AUTHORING THIS BILL IT DOES
SHOW THAT- URBAN AND RURAL HAVE
COMMON INTERESTS MOST ASSUREDLY
WHAT'S SIGNIFICANT HERE IS
ENCOURAGING THE CALIFORNIA
CONSERVATION CORPS
PARTICIPATION TO A GREATER
DEGREE. I WORKED ON THAT ONE
FOR A LONG TIME AND THEY DO A
GREAT JOB THEY'RE WELL TRAINED.
A GOOD EXPERIENCE FOR THEM. AND
IN THAT NOW INMATES ARE MORE
SCARCE TO BE WORKING THEN THE
FIRES AND THE FIRE CAMPS. THE
CCC CAN HELP PICK UP THAT
SLACK. URGE AND I WILL. THREE
FOR THE. THING MAN SAID
BRADFORD YOU MAKE. IRISH
RECKLESS FOR A VOTE. MEMBERS
THIS IS A CAN FOR THE ROLL CALL
THERE ANY A- SEEING NONE I
THIRTY NINE NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES. MEMBERS ARE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER SEVENTY
FOUR. SENATOR WIENER YOU
PREPARED. MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL TEN
THIRTY BY THE COMMITTEE ON
HOUSING AN ACT RELATING TO
HOUSING AND A MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE.
SENATOR WIENER THE FLOOR IS
YOURS I THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT CALLS ARE PRESENT
THIS BILL- ON BEHALF OF THE
COMMITTEE ON HOUSING. HI THIS
IS THE ANNUAL HOUSING ON THE
BUS BILL CONTAINS A- NUMBER OF
TECHNICAL AND NON CONTROVERSIAL
CHANGES. TO CALIFORNIA HOUSING
LAWS. SB TEN THIRTY PASSED OUT
OF THE SENATE HOUSING COMMITTEE
ON CONSENT. AND UNANIMOUSLY OUT
OF THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR RIVAL.
MEMBER IS THERE ANY OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. SEEING NONE THIS
IS ALSO AN ITEM FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION. SEEING NONE I IS
THIRTY NINE NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON
TO ITEM NUMBER SEVENTY FIVE.
SENATOR BRADFORD TODAY'S YOUR
DAY AND HE'S READY SO MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL ELEVEN NINETY TWO BY
SENATOR BRADFORD AND ACT
RELATED INSURANCE THE FLOOR IS
YOURS SIR. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. HELLO NINETY TWO
CREATE SIX PER FOR THE MEMBERS
OF ALL POLICE FIRE AND POLICE
OFFICERS BENEFIT ASSOCIATIONS-
BY OFFERING LONG TERM
DISABILITY AND LONG TERM CARE
BENEFITS THAT ALLOWS THEM TO
ACCESS TO BENEFITS UPON A
WRITTEN REQUEST IT ALSO
REQUIRES A DISCLOSE GREATER
TRANSPARENCY AND LET'S MEMBERS
KNOW THAT THEIR- THEY'RE NOT
PROTECTED AGAINST GOLDEN STATE
BY INSURANCE. SEARCH ATION IN
OUR CARS SELF FUNDING OF
PATIENCE MET ADMIRAL OPTIONS TO
APARTMENT INSURANCE EVERY FOR
YEARS TO SUPPORT A BUYER FOR
COLLEGE NOW KERN COMMISSIONER
US RIVAL. THERE ANY. AND THIS.
SEC NOW THIS IS THE FOR YOU NOW
CONSENT IS A ANY OF WILL. THREE
SAYING NOW THE MEASURE PASSES I
THIRTY NINE NO ZERO MEASURE
PASSES. MEMBERS THAT CAN CAUSE
THIS THERE READING WE'RE GOING
TO ON TO THE ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING. ITEM NUMBER. EIGHTY
SIX. SENATOR UMBERG IS PREPARED
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHT SIXTY BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BERMAN AND AFTER LEADING TO
ELECTIONS AND DECLARING THE
URGENCY THERE OF TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY. SENATOR AMBER
AMBER IS YOURS THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES I
STAND BEFORE YOU PRESENT AB
EIGHT SIXTY- THIS IS THIS BILL-
INSURES THAT. THE ELECTION THE
IS THIS NOVEMBER UNDER THE MOST
UNIQUE OF CIRCUMSTANCES IS ONE
WHERE WE DO OUR UTMOST TO
PROTECT THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
OF CALIFORNIANS WITH THE BILL
DOES THE PRINT ADS THAT. ALL
ACTIVE REGISTERED VOTERS IN
CALIFORNIA WILL RECEIVE A
BALLOT PURPOSES V. THE DROP OFF
OR MAIL IN. WE SEE WHAT HAPPENS
WHEN THERE'S NOT AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR SAFE VOTING WAS. ON APRIL
THE BUT THE PERSONAL. WHERE
THEY WEREN'T ADEQUATE
OPPORTUNITIES AND THERE WERE AT
LEAST SEVEN FOLKS WHO ARE
PERFECT THE. HAIRS IT'S A- THE
BUT IN TO PROVIDING A MAIL IN
BALLOTS THE THERE WILL BE
ANOTHER THAT MAKE SURE THAT WE
ALL HAVE IN PERSON VOTING IN
CALIFORNIA WHICH IS ALSO
CRITICAL- THIS IS A COMMONSENSE
MEASURE PARTICULARLY AT THIS
TIME OF CLOTHING NINETEEN AND I
URGE YOUR VOTE. SENATOR PENN
THINK I THANK YOU A- MA'AM-
PRESIDENTS AND I'VE- WHY STAND
ALSO IN SUPPORT OF- THIS-
IMPORTANT- BILL- CERTAINLY IS A
PHYSICIAN I WOULD SAY THAT THE-
WE'RE TOLD IT'S NOT GOING TO BE
GONE BY NOVEMBER- AND- WE NEED
TO BE SURE THAT WE PROTECT THE
FOUNDATION OF MY THAT'S THE
LEVEL. THE VOTE. DO IT IN A WAY
THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF THE
PEOPLE MONEY ON THE- AND I
THINK THIS IS A VERY STEP IN
THIS. AND SO I URGE IN EITHER
THANK YOU. SENATOR MCGUIRE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MAN A
PRESIDENT FIRST AND FOREMOST- I
WANNA STAND TODAY AND SAY THANK
YOU TO THE CHAIRMAN FROM
ELECTIONS THAT FOR HIS
INCREDIBLE WORK ON THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE I AND THE
COLLABORATION THAT HE HAS BEEN
ADVANCING WITH THE ASSEMBLY AS
WELL I DO WANT TO SAY HOW
GRATEFUL WE ARE TO CHAIR. I IN
I THINK IT LOT OF MINE IS IT
YOUR CAL VOTERS ROD VOTING BY
MAIL THAT WE'VE FROM ABOUT 3%
3% IN IN THE THANK SIXTIES OUT
THERE TH. CALIFORNIA WITH ME.
APPROACH 80% THE ONE AREA WHERE
THE CHAIRMAN IT HAS BEEN
WORKING ON IN NO THERE'S A NEED
BE A WORK IS WITHIN THOSE
COUNTIES IN FOR TO CONVERSE
WITH THE CHAIRMAN OF ELECTIONS
ON THE ISSUE OF RURAL COUNTIES
ELECTIONS AND JUST WANNA STAND
TODAY IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL IN
THE FOR TO THOSE ADDITIONAL
CONVERSATIONS WITH THOSE
ELECTION OFFICIALS. SENATE
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT ARMY
ONE OF ONE OF THE FEW
REPUBLICANS IT ACTUALLY IS A
ADVOCATE PROVOKED BY MAIL- BY.
CAME TO A LOT OF RESEARCH IN-
WHEN I WAS A COUNTY SUPERVISOR
AND MORE THAN 60% OF OUR
RESIDENTS THAT ARE REGISTERED
ALREADY VOTING BY MAIL SO THE
TREND IS YOUR FRIEND. SO IF I
MAY MISTER. SORRY MY APOLOGIES
BETTER AS IT MAY I PLEASE ASK.
THE FLOOR. SHOP HERE QUESTIONS
AND THEN CLOSE WITH SOME COMMON.
SENATOR AMBER BURKE WILL YOU
TAKE A QUESTION THANK YOU
PRESENT I WOULD WELCOME A
QUESTION FROM SOME MORE LAW.
THANK YOU AGAIN JUST TO BE
ASKING QUESTIONS FROM- SENATOR
FROM ORANGE COUNTY. WHAT WHAT
ARE THE PENALTIES FOR VOTER
FRAUD. WELL I'M NOT EXACTLY
SURE WHAT THE PENALTIES FOR
VOTER FRAUD IF YOU- I ASSUME
THERE'S SOME CRIMINAL PENALTY I
WOULD BE HAPPY TO GET BACK TO
YOU. WE YOU KNOW WE KEEP
GETTING STORIES SENATOR- MAYBE
PEOPLE TAKING A MAIL OUT OF AN
OPEN MAILBOX OR NOT MAILED IN
THERE AND THEN THAT THOSE CAN
BE STOLEN. APARTMENT IT'S
REALLY JUST FOR PERSON RIGHT
NOW GET ALL THE- SO. BUT IS WE
WERE BE NICE KNOW WE GET ASK
QUESTION. WHAT'S WHAT'S THE
PENALTY. FOR DOING CERTAIN
THINGS AND OF COURSE I MAY HAVE
A DIFFICULTY FINDING ACTUAL
CASES OF VOTER FRAUD BUT WE
CERTAINLY STORIES FROM BOTH
SIDES OF THE AISLE. INCLUDING
SENATOR LUGAR. AT FOUND JUST A
LOT OF IT. OF THESE TYPES OF.
CONCERNS WITH WE GETTING TICKET.
AND THAT THE SECOND QUESTION IS
WHY DO WE. SEVENTEEN AFTER
ELECTION DAY. WELL THE I THINK
THE QUESTION IN A MORE LIKE
GOES TO HOW LONG THE REGS HEY
TO BE TALLY THE THAT COME IN IF
YOU'RE A BALLOT CLOSE BY DAY
THEN THE REGISTRAR CAN COUNT
THAT BALLOT FOR SEVERAL DAYS
AFTER THE ELECTION AND THE
REASON IS A IS STOP. I ARE
CLOSE OFFICE IS USE. QUITE A
FISH ON OCCASION THEY'RE NOT A
AS WE'D LIKE THEM TO BE AND SO
WE DON'T WANT TO DISENFRANCHISE
AND WON- NOT THROUGH ANY FAULT
OF THEIR OWN BUT BECAUSE THE
POST OFFICE. MAYES LIVER. WELL
THAT'S THE- SURE THAT. ARE
EVERYONE UNDERSTANDS THE BALLOT
MUST BE POSTMARKED BY ELECTION
DAY. THANK YOU THAT ANSWERS
THAT QUESTION IS THE THIRD
QUESTION. HOW DO WE JUSTIFY AN
ADDITIONAL THIRTY FIVE MILLION
IN THE GENERAL FUND NOW THAT WE
ARE IN A- RECESSION. WILL BE
HOPING THE NEXT. A FEW DAYS ON
A BY. PERHAPS SOME SO CUTS OF.
THE YOU KNOW HOW WHAT ARE THE
COSTS BENEFIT CAN HER COULD YOU
ADDRESS THAT. SO OF THE A GOOD
QUESTION IN IN OUR BUDGET IS A
STATEMENT OF OUR VALUES AND
WHAT WE PRIORITIZE- THE
ELECTION IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT TO PRESERVATION OF
OUR DEMOCRACY AND IN
FRANCHISING AS MANY AS POPS.
WELL IS INCREDIBLY INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT I BELIEVE THAT THE
MARGINAL JUST CHECKED ON THE
CITY THE MARGINAL COST IS ABOUT
THIRTEEN MILLION DOLLARS THAT
THIS BILL WOULD ADD EPISODE YES
THE THERE IS A- TEMA DOLLARS.
BUT WE'RE A VERY POOL BAR BUT I
BELIEVE THAT THE TEAM MAY
DOLLARS IN SCHOOLS. THANK YOU
ITEM PER TO WITH SOME FOR.
CURRENTLY CAL. IS THE STAY. IN
THE NATION HAS. ISSUED ITS JUNE
THIRD. TWENTY NINETEEN. AUDITED
FINANCIAL STATEMENTS. WE SHOULD
HAVE BEEN DONE FOR MOST LARGE
MUNICIPALITIES SHOULD BE DONE
WITHIN SIX MONTHS FROM
DECEMBER- CALIFORNIA
HISTORICALLY HAS BEEN DONE
AROUND APRIL- WE CONTACT THE
STATE COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE AND
WE WERE TOLD IT PROBABLY WON'T
BE UNTIL SEPTEMBER SO. DARK
DEAL THAT OF ALL THE STATES
WERE NOT. SHOWING PEOPLE ARE
FINANCIAL STATE. AS FAR A
LITTLE CONCERNED SO WE CALL THE-
STATE CONTROLLERS OFFICE IN
THEY SAID THAT THERE WERE TWO
DEPARTMENTS THAT WERE HOLDING
UP. THE COMPREHENSIVE ANNUAL
FINANCIAL REPORT. ONE OF THEM
BEING THE SECRETARY OF STATE.
SO COLLEAGUES ARE JUST KIND OF
CONCERNED OF WHAT'S GOING ON IN
THE SECRETARY OF STATE'S
DEPARTMENT IT IT HAS A
PERCEPTION OF BEATING **** TIME
JUST KIND OF STERN WE CERTAINLY
NOT THE MUSE HAPPEN WITH MOTOR
VOTER BEING IMPLEMENTED WILL
TOO SOON. WHAT THE SOFTWARE NOT
AVAILABLE AND CREATED QUITE A
MESS. I REALLY WANT TO PORT A.
EIGHT SIXTY BUT I'M NERVOUS
ABOUT ABUSE. ABOUT A COSTS IN
I'M NERVOUS OF THE SECOND OF
STATE'S. THAT APPEARS TO BE.
STRUGGLING OR WHATEVER
FLOUNDERING WHATEVER'S
HAPPENING OVER THERE OF THE
TREND IS YOUR FRIEND AND I ARE
WHAT I. WANT I WANT TO VOTE FOR
SOMETHING THAT I. DIRECTLY
SUPPORTED BUT I'M I JUST RAISED
SOME CONCERNS ABOUT THE CURRENT
STATUS OF- THE ONE DEPARTMENT
AND HOW REFLECTS ON THE REST OF
THE STATE THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. SENATOR HERTZBERG.
THERE ARE A FEW THINGS. WE DO
IN OUR DEMOCRACY THAT INFORMS
OUR DEMOCRACY. THE ALLOW PEOPLE.
PARTICIPATION DEVOTE THAT
DEFINES THE ESSENCE OF OUR FORM
OF GOVERNMENT. THAT ALL PEOPLE
HAVE A VOICE. WE HAVE DECADES
IN THIS INSTITUTION. DOING
EVERYTHING POSSIBLE TO REMOVE
BARRIERS TO GIVE ALL PEOPLE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE THAT VOICE.
WE FOUND IN DURING THE BUSH
VERSUS GORE CASE THAT THEY WERE
53% OF THE MACHINES IN
CALIFORNIA THE HANGING CHAD
PROBLEMS. THE VOTERS AUTHORIZED
TO TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
BOND ISSUE TO FIX THAT. WE
TALKED TO FOLKS THAT- OFTEN A
RENTERS IN. REVENUE PLACE AND
FIND OUT THAT THE THIRTY DAY
LIMITATION ON. REGISTRATION
INHIBITED A WHOLE HOST OF
PEOPLE TO VOTE. WE MOVED TO
FIFTEEN DAYS AND THEN KIND OF A
PARTIAL SAME DAY REGISTRATION.
A FEW YEARS AGO. LOOK AT THIS
IDEA VOTE CENTERS. FOLKS WORK
ACROSS TOWN CAN'T GET BACK HOME
BECAUSE THEY GOT PROBLEMS OF
THEIR KIDS OR THIS OR SICK OR
WORK OR SOMETHING AND THEY MISS
VOTING. SO WE SET UP VOTE
CENTERS WITH ELIMINATE THE
TRADITIONAL VOTING PLACES WOULD
REDUCE THE FEW BECAUSE OF COSTS
BUT THE REALITY IS. HE WANTED
TO VOTE YOUR COMMITTEE YOU
COULD. SOME HAVE GONE TO ALMOST
ALL VOTE BY. IT'S WHAT WE'RE
DOING HERE I DIDN'T DO TO BUILD
THIS FEEL THE WHEN I FIRST GOT
HERE INSTEAD WE CHOSE TO PURSUE
THE ISSUE CENTERS SOME COUNTIES
FELT THIS WOULD BE TOO
EXPENSIVE. BUT SIR OF THE
PANDEMIC CHAO. WITH THE LARGER
DYNAMIC IS WE AS ELECTED
OFFICIALS SHOULD DO EVERYTHING
POSSIBLE TO PROVIDE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR EVERYBODY ON
EVERY CIRCUMSTANCE TO
PARTICIPATE AND SO THIS IS JUST
ONE IT DOESN'T ELIMINATE PEOPLE
VOTING THEIR COMMITTEE THE
PRECINCTS IT DOESN'T A LOT BUT
I PEOPLE VOTING OTHER VOTE
CENTERS OF FAT STATE WHAT
CHOOSE TO DO. IT DOES IN THE
ELIMINATE. THREE LATE BECAUSE-
THEY WORK ON THE LA WHAT IT IS.
I JUST STOPPED A MOMENT BECAUSE
THIS IS. AN IMPORTANT ISSUE. IT
IS IMPORTANT ISSUE BACKED UP BY
ELECTIONS CODE SECTION EIGHTEEN
THOUSAND AT SAC. THAT PROVIDES
FOR IN VARIOUS VIOLATIONS OF
THE CODE UP TO THREE YEARS
IMPRISONMENT TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLAR FINES. FOR
COMMITTING FRAUD IN THE
ELECTION PROCESS AND THERE'S A
WHOLE HOST OF WAYS THAT'S DONE.
SO THERE IS A VERY DEEP SET OF
TEETH BEHIND PEOPLE WHO ENGAGE
IN VOTER FRAUD BUT YOU MARRY
THAT AGAINST THE ESSENCE OF WHO
WE ARE AS A DEMOCRACY AND WE
SHOULD PASS THIS BILL. WITH
GREAT ENERGY YOUR EYES ON.
SENATOR DR OF. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR NO I SPEND MOST OF MY-
MOVING ORGANIZING AND
MOBILIZING PEOPLE IN OUR
COMMUNITY TO SPEAK UP. AND ONE
WAY WAS TO REGISTER TO VOTE
ANOTHER WAY WAS TO MAKE SURE
YOU GOT OUT TO VOTE IN FACT IN
ONE CAMPAIGN WE USE THE TERM
IMPAIR THE KNOBBLY. THAT IF YOU
HAVE THE RIGHT TO VOTE IT IS
UNFORGIVABLE TO NOT EXERCISE
THAT RIGHT BOMB TODAY WE HAVE
AN OPPORTUNITY TO ALSO MAKE
SURE THAT PEOPLE WHO DO WANT TO
VOTE DO THE RIGHT TO. THE
EXERCISE THAT BOAT BY MAKING
ANOTHER OP AVAIL TO THEM. THIS
MEASURE MAKE SURE THAT EVERY I
JUST HAD VOTER IN CALIFORNIA
RIGHT TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
ELECTION IS SICK. NO ONE SHOULD
HAVE TO DECIDE BETWEEN
PARTICIPATE IN THE ELECTION AND
THEIR PUBLIC HEALTH IF THEY ARE
NOT COMFORTABLE PHYSICALLY
GOING TO STAND IN LINE TO CAST
THEIR BALLOTS. LET'S NOT FORGET
THAT THE COLD NINETEEN PANDEMIC
IS STILL GOING ON AND WE DO NOT
KNOW WHEN IT WILL END. UP OUT
OF THAT CALIFORNIA. SIXTY PER
CENT CALIFORNIA VOTERS ARE NOW
PERMANENT VOTE BY MAIL VOTERS.
MY HOME COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES
AND FOURTEEN OTHER COUNTIES- I
HAVE. THE COLLECTIONS ARE WHERE
IN EVERY REGISTERED VOTER
RECEIVES A BALLOT IN THE MAIL-
I SUPPORT AB EIGHT SIXTY AS AN
IMPORTANT STEP TO PROTECT
VOTING RIGHTS TO IT ALL
CALIFORNIA VOTERS ARE NOT
FORCED TO CHOOSE BETWEEN THEIR
HALF OF AN EXERCISING THEIR
RIGHT TO VOTE THAT AND- SEND.
BAIT YEAH. ALL CAN YOU HEAR ME
NOW YEAH THANK YOU CAN READ I
HAVE COME NOT OF THE VOTE BY
MAIL PROCESS CITY WORKED WELL
OUR IN OUR IN COUNTY IS A
MEMBER OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS WITH MY GOOD
COLLEAGUE AND FRIEND THE COSTA
MESA. I DIDN'T SUPPORT SO
MOVING TOTALLY TO THAT WE HAVE
AND YET THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
THAT AND IT HAS WORKED WELL
THAT IS NOT MY CONCERN MY
CONCERN AGAIN GOES TO THE
SEVENTEEN DAY I DELAY AND THAT
THAT'S REALLY A PROBLEM
CERTAINLY FOR EVERY COUNTY.
GENES ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED.
WHETHER YEAH WE WIN THEIR SEAT
FOR LOSE THEIR SEAT. ARE THERE
THERE HAS BEEN NO DATA PRESENT
TO A TO DO. SEVEN DAY WHEN IT
TO THAT THE AT. IS STILL IN
CHARGE OF A MALE IT IS GOING TO
TAKE TWO AND A HALF WEEKS TO
GET THERE. SO I YOU ARE WILL
NOT SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY.
THAT I URGE OUR AUTHOR AND OUR
JOCKEY TO TAKE A LOOK AT THAT
IN AT LEAST BANDS. IN FACT FOR
ME AS TO WHAT. WE PICKS. DAY
OUT OF. OUR THAT DOES. SO THE
PEOPLE WHO AGREE CONCERN ABOUT
THIS. DATING FRAUD AND I WE
OUGHT ARE ELECTION SYSTEM TO BE.
FOR THE FOR. BY ELECT. AND
UNDERSTAND THE IS FAIR. ARE
THAT IS JUST IT'S- IN A
ACCURATE. SEVEN DAYS. AS THE
THEIR SOME UP AGAIN THERE IN WE
DON'T NEED MORE CA. THEORY
GOING ON ON WITH REGARDS TO
ELECTIONS SO I URGE AND NOBLE.
LAYING OFF. STILL THERE TEENS.
WE GO AHEAD AND TAKE THE
QUESTIONS AND HE CAN ANSWER
THOSE QUESTIONS. IN THE
CLOTHES. THAT'S APPROPRIATE. I
HAVE TO AGREE WITH MY COLLEAGUE
FROM LOS ANGELES THAT. VOTING
IS THE BEATING HEART OF OUR
DEMOCRACY. MAKING CERTAIN THAT
PEOPLE PARTICIPATE IS PART AND
PARCEL OF THE AMERICAN
EXPERIENCE. I THINK WE'VE HEARD
THAT. ROSS THIS IS ALSO A
SIGNIFICANT COMPONENT OF OUR
LEGAL SYSTEM. AND SO I THINK WE
HAVE TO MARRY OUT. THE
PRAGMATIC ASPECTS VOTING AS
WELL AS MAKING CERTAIN THAT
WE'RE LOOKING AFTER THE
ADMINISTRATIVE AND LEGAL
IMPLICATIONS OF OUR DECISION.
SO I. ONE OF THE QUESTIONS I
HAVE IS. IF WE ARE GOING INTO A
ALL RICH ALL REGISTRANTS ARE
GETTING A BALLOT. OR WE'RE
EXPERTS I IMAGINE WE'RE GONNA
BE EXPECTING A HIGHER TURNOUT
BY VIRTUE OF THAT. DO YOU DO WE
HAVE ANY EXPERIENCE CHATTING
WITH THE- COUNTY IS ON WHAT THE
WOULD ANTICIPATE TO BE THE
INCREASED VOLUME OF VOTER
PARTICIPATION IN A GIVEN COUNTY
AND WHERE I'M GOING WITH THAT
IS I THINK THERE'S A COST HERE
THAT YOU WERE NOT POPULATING
OUT BECAUSE IF WE PRIEST. BUT
TO BEAR THE BRUNT OF THIS NEW
POLICY. I'M WONDERING IF THERE
SHOULD BE. OPERATION ATTACHED
TO THIS NEW PROGRAM. BECAUSE I
THINK THAT THAT WOULD BE KEY
KEY BECAUSE THE VOTING IS
SACROSANCT BUT- THE
TRUSTWORTHINESS OF VOTING I
THINK IS TERRIBLY IMPORTANT SO
MY OTHER QUESTION IS IT ONLY
THE SERIAL THAT IS MAILED BY
THE REGISTRAR OF VOTERS TO THE
REGISTRANT. FIVE THAT ALLOWS
THE INDIVIDUAL TO- CAST A VOTE
FOR CAN SOMEONE GO TO A
COMPUTER PRINTOUT A BALLOT AND
USE THAT AS SOME FORM OF PROXY.
IS THAT I THINK IS GOES ALSO TO
THE AMOUNT OF DOLLARS THAT A
COUNTY REGISTRAR IS GOING TO
NEED A CLERK IS GOING TO NEED
TO MAKE CERTAIN THAT. EACH TOM
JONES OR TOM OR JONES OR TOM H.
R. JONES ANY NAME VARIATIONS
THAT WE HAVE IN THESE COUNTIES-
WERE INDIVIDUALS GET MULTIPLE
BALLOTS I THINK WE CAN ALL
ATTEST- THAT- SOME FOLKS
RECEIVE MULTIPLE BALLOTS BY
NAME VARIATION I THINK I'VE GOT
MY- THERE'S BALLOT. ABOUT FOR
TIMES BECAUSE WE HAVE THE SAME
MAY FIRST MET AND NAME IN SAME
PER. IF THOUGH I'M NOT NINETY
YEARS. SO I THINK THERE'S AN
INNER FROM INNER SAFEGUARD THAT
I THINK WOULD BE HEALTH AND
LASTLY IS THAT SEVENTY DAISY
ISSUE. I'M CAN BECAUSE RIGHT
NOW. ARE NOT THE RULES THAT. AN
INDIVIDUAL MUST PUT IN THE MAIL
THEIR PAPER BALLOT BY ELECTION
DAY. IS A BALLOT STILL GOOD IF
IT'S MAILED OR DROPPED IN A BOX
TWO DAYS LATER. IN THE WAS IT
WAS THAT AND NOW. ALL RIGHT. WE
HAVE TO HAVE TIME DEFINITE IN
THIS SEVENTEEN DAY VISIT EXTEND
THE THIRTY DAY WINDOW THAT A-
THAT A COUNTY CLERK. USES JUST
FINE ELECTION. DOES THAT CHANGE
THAT THIRTY DAY WINDOW SO DOES
IT MAKE IT FORTY SEVEN NOW I
DON'T KNOW I THINK THERE'S A
LOT OF QUESTIONS I'M HOPEFUL
THAT THE SENATOR CAN ADDRESS
THEM ALL IN HIS CLOSING
STATEMENTS OR RESPOND DIRECTLY
NOW. THAT SENATOR JACKSON'S.
YES THANK YOU IN RESPONSE TO AN
EARLIER INQUIRY ABOUT VOTER
FRAUD- YOU KNOW THIS IS A BIG
MANTRA BECAUSE- REALLY THE
EFFORT IS TO TRY TO SUPPRESS
THE VOTE. US LET'S BE. WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT HERE THERE ARE SO
FEW CASES OF ACTUAL VOTER
FRAUD- I THINK STUDIES HAVE
SHOWN THAT SINCE THE YEAR TWO
THOUSAND IN CALIFORNIA. BY TWO
TWO THOUSAND AND TWELVE THERE
WERE A TOTAL OF FIFTY SIX. THE
SIX CASES OF VOTER FRAUD AND
HOW MANY MILLIONS OF VOTES.
WERE CAST BUT IF THERE IS GREAT
CONCERN. ABOUT THE PENALTIES
FOR VOTER FRAUD. OUR COMMITTEE
AND OR ATTEMPTING TO COMMIT
VOTER FRAUD WILL GET SOMEONE UP
TO THREE YEARS IN PRISON IT IS
A FELONY. TAMPERING WITH THE
VOTING SYSTEM. COULD GET YOU UP
TO FOUR YEARS IN PRISON.
CHANGING OR WRONGFULLY PLACING
BALLOTS IS A FINE UP TO A
THOUSAND DOLLARS AND UP TO
THREE YEARS IN PRISON. MISS
LEADING A VOTER WHO NEEDS
ASSISTANCE IS UP TO THREE YEARS
IN PRISON AND INTERFERING WITH
THE VOTE BY MAIL BALLOT CAN GET
YOU UP TO SIX MONTHS IN THE
COUNTY JAIL AND A FINE OF UP TO
TEN. DOLLARS NOTION NUMBER VOTE
FRAUD IN THIS GREAT CONCERN
ABOUT IT IN FACT THE CASES OF
VOTER FRAUD THEY FOUND EARLIER
WERE ACTUALLY COMMITTED BY
CAMPAIGN OFFICIALS AND NOT
VOTERS. SO THE FACT OF THE
MATTER IS. THAT IN THE NATION
THE PRIDES ITSELF ON ITS
DEMOCRATIC PROCESS IN A NATION
WHERE WE HAVE SANTA OTHERS TO
BE OVERSEERS AN OBSERVER IN THE
SHINS IN OTHER COUNTRIES. IF WE
DO NOT VALUE THE RIGHT OF EVERY
PERSON TO VOTE. WHO IS
QUALIFIED TO VOTE THEN WE
REALLY. DEMOCRATS GO AROUND THE
WORLD WERE OTHER COUNTRIES ARE
CASTING BALLOTS AND IN FACT IF
YOU SAW THE EMBARRASSING MASS
THE RECORD TRUSTS TWO DAYS AGO
IN GEORGIA. WHAT THERE ARE SOME
THAT WAS WHAT A DISGRACE TO OUR
DEMOCRATIC PULLS. WHY WHICH-
THAT IF IT TAKES DAYS. IT WILL
ALLOW IT THERE'S A REQUEST
ABOUT THE BULLET OF A BALLOT IT
ALLOWS THE REGISTRAR TO DO THAT
EXAMINATION WHICH RAISES. THE
MEME- ALL UP ALL THE SOME OF
OUR FOLKS WHO REALLY DON'T WANT
PEOPLE VOTED. SO SEVENTEEN
ISN'T REALLY THAT MUCH I CAN
YOU HAVING BEEN INVOLVED IN A
HOTLY CONTESTED ELECTION
SEVERAL YEARS AGO. IT WAS MORE
THAN SEVENTEEN DAYS TO GET ALL
THE BALLOTS COUNTED IN GET THAT
ELECTION VERIFY SO SEVENTEEN
DAYS THE MAGIC NUMBER- BUT WE
WANT THE PROCESS. TO ENCOURAGE
PEOPLE TO PUT AND CERTAINLY IN
THE COLD AT NIGHT IT SHOULD
ASIAN WHERE. WILL BE WILL BLOOD
INTO. WE TAKE THE RIGHT OF
VOTING EXCEL TO EVERY. THIS
NOTION ABOUT HOW ALL THIS FRAUD
IS COMMITTED IS TRUST A FARCE.
IT IS NOT KILL IT IS NOT
ACCURATE THE NUMBERS DO NOT
SUPPORTED AND FRANKLY THEY
NEVER HAVE SO I AM WILL TRY TO
BUY THIS CONTINUED FRUSTRATION
ABOUT THING THAT HAS BEEN
DISPROVEN OVER AND OVER AND
OVER AGAIN. WHAT WE SHOULD DO
IT WE VALUE TO THE FUNDAMENTAL
PRINCIPLES COUNTRY LAST I
LOOKED. SHOULD BE IN PART. IF
IT COSTS AN EXTRA THIRTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR THAT IS A SMALL
PRICE TO PAY TO CONTINUEWOULD
DEMOCRATIC PROCESS WHEN THE
VOICE OF THE PEOPLE TO BE HEARD
IT IS AT LEAST AS STAND THAT
THE MENTAL IMPRESSION I. THAT I.
SENATE WEST OF. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH LAYS GENTLEMEN THIS IS A
OF A ISSUE WITH THAT WE BEEN
JUST HERE FOR MANY NOT ONLY
HERE AND LET BUT FOR PRIOR.
ALWAYS WHEN. WE UP ABOUT BUT OF
COURSE THERE LOTS OF. WHY WHY
WE DON'T HAVE BEEN. BATTLE MIND
OF THAT BUT I WOULD REMIND
EVERYBODY WE'RE GOING TO MAIL
IN BALLOTS BECAUSE OF. DEMOCRAT
FACED. AND CURRENTLY CAL. IF
YOU COULD CASES WERE WORSE IN
INCREASE. AN INFECTION CASES
RIGHT NOW RIGHT NOW IS THE TIME
FOR US TO REALLY CONSIDER THIS
AN- AND DO WHAT'S RIGHT BY. OF
THE CONTAINER SCHOOL. KEY IN
KEEPING OUR OUR POLL WORKER
SAFER MEMBER PER WORKERS ARE
LARGE RETIRED INDIVIDUALS. ARE
THEY ARE VOLUNTEERS THEIR
TEMPORARY WORKERS AND THEY THEY
ARE ON THE- SPECTRUM ABOUT SOME
OF THE PEOPLE THAT ARE. OF A OF
LOSE A LOT OF AN A- INFECTION.
WE HAVE TO THINK ABOUT THEM AS
WELL- EVERY POLL WORKER GETS
CONTACT WITH A POTENTIALLY
HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE IN ONE
SINGLE DAY. IN WHEN ONE SINGLE
MOMENT AND THAT IS A THREAT TO
THEIR LIVES AND WE CAN SEE THAT
BUT I ALSO WORRY EVERYONE THAT
WE VOTING. OF THE SET IS
GENERALLY BEEN QUITE A- FOR YOU
KNOW WHERE FRAUD IS FOUND IN
THE VOTING PROCESS- IT'S BEEN
SOMETHING THAT'S BEEN TO. FOR
THAT LONG YEAH AND YOU KNOW IN
MY EXPERIENCE. WHAT WHAT THE
NORMAL- A IN THE PAST ELECTIONS
I HAVE WITNESSED THAT AND IT'S
KIND OF KNOWN THAT THE- THIRD
THE LARGE UP OF THE LAW CHECK
OF OUR- CONCERT. SALEM BUT THEN
THEN THE ELECTION THAT'S ALL
BEEN A SORE OF DEBATE IF WE GO
TO IN WHO IS THAT. WHO'S PART
MORE AND THAT'S BEEN THE SUB
BUT- AS I'VE SPOKEN TO PAY IN
CARS THEM. TO VOTE BALLOT LET
OF THEM TELL ME I ENJOY. GOING
TO THE POLLS I WANT TO GO TO
THE POLLS. AND THAT'S US A
SOMETHING THAT WE NEED TO
ADDRESS IN THIS PARTICULAR
TIME. AND SEASON. IN WE'RE
FACING A PANDEMIC THAT SERVER
KILLING SO MANY AMERICANS. MORE
MORE AMERICANS ARE DYING FROM
THIS FIVE AND ANY THE WAY. OKAY
ADDRESS ACCOUNT AND ARE BOSS
EVERY COUNTY IS ALREADY SET UP
TO RESPOND TO THE REGISTERED
VOTERS THAT THEY HAVE ON FILE.
OR ARE THEY ALREADY HAVE A
BUDGET TO ADDRESS- THE PUT TO
THE POSSIBILITY OF A 100% VOTER
TURNOUT AND THAT'S WHAT'S IN
THERE BUT THAT'S WHAT THEY'RE
EXPECTED TO DO THAT'S THEIR JOB
WE DON'T HAVE TO BACK FILL FUND
BECAUSE OUR READY. I'M PREPARED
TO DO THAT AND IN THE EVENT
THAT THEY'RE NOT THAT'S NOT
THIS LEGISLATURE'S FAULT THAT'S
A LOCAL DECISION THAT WAS MADE.
BACK A LOWER TURNOUT DO WE
EXPECT THAT EVERYBODY THAT'S
REGISTER THE VOTES GOING TO
VOTE WELL YEAH REASONABLY WE
ACCEPT THAT BREAKS UP THAT
THEY'RE NOT BUT WE HAVE TO
PREPARE IN CASE THEY DO. I
BELIEVE THAT PICK MORE PEOPLE
WILL OR WILL PARTY. BECAUSE OF
AMOUNT HONESTLY I DON'T. I
THINK WE'LL GET THE SAME
RESULTS AND THERE MIGHT BE SOME
PEOPE TAT JUST. ELECT NOT TO
VOTE BY MY MAIL AND THAT'S THE
UNFORTUNATE PART OF THIS
PROCESS IF WE DO. WE WOULD GET
A 100% PARTICIPATION BY MAIL IN
BALLOT BELIEVE ME WHY WOULDN'T
WE DO THAT. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN EVERYBODY TO VOTE.
THAT'S THE AMERICAN THE SPARE
IN THE AMERICAN SPIRIT LET'S
GET EVERYBODY. TO VOTE. BUT THE
REAL THREAT. THE REAL FOR. THE
BIGGEST THREAT TO VOTER FRAUD
HAPPENING IN OUR COUNTRY WE
HAVE TO BE HONEST LADIES AND
GENTLEMAN IT'S VOTER
SUPPRESSION AND I APPRECIATE MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SANTA BARBARA
RAISING THE INCIDENT OF GEORGIA
WHERE PEOPLE WAITED. HOURS AND
HOURS IN LINE. BECAUSE IT
INSTEAD OF SOCIAL DISTANCING
YOU HAD. BLOCKS AND BLOCKS OF
THE LINE WHY THEY REDUCE THE
POLLING SITES AND THAT TO THAT
DISASTER OF THE MET THE VOTER
MACHINES WERE NOT OPERATIONAL
AND THAT WAS A DESK MR THEY
DIDN'T HAVE ENOUGH POLL
WORKERS. DESTIN'S THAT ALSO
VOTERS ARE BEING HURT. THE
FILES. AND THAT IS THE BIGGEST
FRAUD HAPPENING IN OUR COUNTRY
RIGHT NOW WHEN SOMEBODY
REGISTERED TO VOTE. EVERY
SINGLE YEAR EVERY COUNTY GOES
THROUGH- THOSE LISTS THEY THEY
COMPARE- THOSE LISTS TO DEATH
CERTIFICATES TO ROOT OUT PEOPLE
THAT WAY. I WAS ACTUALLY
CONTACTED BECAUSE I'VE BEEN
REGISTERED FOR SO LONG. THAT
MIGHT SIGNATURE OVER THE OVER
THE COURSE OF THOSE YEARS HAS
BEGUN TO CHANGE AND I WAS ACT
CONTACT TO THE FILLUP NEW. UP
ISSHIN AND I DO. OUR SIGNATURE.
THE THING THAT THAT'S OF IRAN
OF ABSENTEE BY HAVE TO BE
COMPARED TO SIGNAL. AND THAT'S
A SAFE AND THEY HAVE TO THEY AT
YOUR BILL THAT'S A SAFE
GUARDING CANCER OF TO APPEAL BY
THAT'S- THERE ARE LOTS OF
SAFEGUARDS I'M NOT SAYING IT'S
PERFECT. I'M JUST. THAT'S BUT
TO OUR ELECTIONS LIES AND I
SUPPORTERS BECAUSE OF. I
SUPPORT THIS BECAUSE OF THE
PANDEMIC AND ALL RIGHT NOW I
THINK PEOPLE- WE HAVE THEIR
ATTENTION IT'S TIME FOR US TO
SPEND THE NEXT SEVERAL MONTHS
KTM VOTER. THIS PROCESS EVERY
WILL A BALLOT WILL C<c.cyan> HAVE</c>
TO EXPLAIN TO THEM THAT THEY
THIS WILL. INCREASE THEIR
SUSPENSION I THINK IT'S LIKELY
THAT IT WILL RESULT IN THE BACK
EITHER WAY. I LET ME DREAM
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN US AND
PLEASE- OFFER THE SAKE OF ALL
OUR POOR WORKERS FOR THE SAKE
OF ALL THE VOTERS. OF THE SAKE
UP TO SEE THE EX OF THIS
PANDEMIC FOR THIS. SENATOR THE
MAN IN THANK YOU YEAH TO SPEAK
ON THE ISSUE OUR FIRST OF ALL I
THINK THIS IS JUST A GOOD
COMMON SENSE MAY THE WILL ONLY
KEEP TELL HEALTHY BUT TYPICALLY
IN I THINK THAT THE MARKET
WORKS ONLY WHEN EVERY SINGLE
VOICES. WANTED TO SPEAK FOR THE
ACT OF THE A LOT COULD OCCUR
WHICH ARE AT ELECTION LOCALLY
FOR YEARS I WAS CAST THEIR
ASIAN. COME FROM STRANGERS I
THINK THE BIGGEST COMPLAINT I
HEARD WAS NOT- BROUGHT IT WAS
LITERALLY THROWING OUT
LEGITIMATE. VOTERS OUT BECAUSE
THEIR SIGNATURES THAT IN MATCH
AND IT SPEAKS TO WHAT MY
COLLEAGUE SAID FROM- AND
VEHICLE. THAT IS SOMETHING
BLOOD VERY FULLY HOT. SO AGAIN
IT'S NOT AS THE A SELECT
BALLOTS THE SUBMITTING THEM
THEY'RE STILL VERIFICATION.
THIS AND- THE BILL BONTA.
THROWING LEGITIMATE DOLLARS
BECAUSE THAT WOULD BE A
SIGNATURE IS MAX SO THEN WE
WOULD BE ON THE UPPER TO
AGAINST A META ON UPDATED
SIGNET BUT I JUST WANT TO SAY
THAT THIS IS REALLY IMPORTANT-
AT THE WILL. THE EIGHT. ARE TO
ME THAT IS NOT DEMOCRACY. THE
ELDERLY WALKED AWAY. BOB WOMEN
WITH CHILDREN WALKED AWAY. WHEN
YOU'RE HAVING TO STAND IN A
LINE FOR FOUR FIVE HOURS. THAT
IS REALLY NOT. THE GOAL I THINK
OF CALIFORNIA AT LEAST FOR
STATE OUR GOAL IS SURE. ONCE I
GET THAT. IS HEARD AND I. WANT
TO SUPPORT THE SMASHED THANK
YOU. YOUR SKIN. THANK YOU I'VE.
MADAM PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS SO
I REALIZE THAT OUR RULES OR ARE
CAN SEE AN THIS FLOORS NOT
TENDENCY OUR INTENT IS TO HAVE
OUR DISCOURSE POLITE. BUT I'M
NOT FEWER SO POLITE RIGHT NOW.
AND I THINK MAYBE IT SAYS I'VE
BEEN HOME ABOUT THREE MONTHS I
THINK LIKE MOST OF YOU. AND
HAD. THE BEEN WATCHING. MANY
MORE MEDIA SOURCES THAN I HAD
LUXURY TO DO BEFORE. IN READING
MANY MORE FIVE REPORTS AND
EDITORIALS. AND I HAVE BEEN
APPALLED. AT THE EXPLICIT
STATEMENTS BY. REPUBLICANS IN
OTHER PARTS OF OUR COUNTRY.
THAT HAVE BASICALLY WHERE THEY
EXPLICITLY STATED THAT THEIR
OPPOSITION TO VOTE BY MAIL
BALLOTS WAS BECAUSE IT WOULD
INCREASE TURNOUT AND THUS
POTENTIALLY THREATEN THEIR
ELECTORAL. CHANCES OUT I AM NOT
SAYING THAT MY COLLEAGUES HERE
ON THIS FLOOR FEEL THAT WAY I'M
JUST REPORTING. FACTUAL WHAT
WAS STATED IN HER. AND IT CALLS
ME. BUT THE LEAST THEIR UP
FRONT ABOUT THEIR REASONS SO
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT VOTER
SUPPRESSION WE KNOW THAT IT IS
A PRESS BY MANY AS A FINE ART.
STRONG BUT I WOULD SAY THAT
WHILE WE'VE SPOKEN ABOUT THE
PANDEMIC. AND YES IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT TO GIVE PEOPLE
OPTIONS TO NOT HAVE TO GO OUT
DURING A PANDEMIC WE SHOULD DO
VOTE BY MAIL REGARDLESS. AND
NOT ONLY THAT. WE SHOULD HAVE
AUTOMATIC LITTER REGISTRATION.
IS NOT REQUIRED THAT'S NOT THE
SAME AS A FAILURE. WHERE TO
VOTE WHICH IS THE AUSTRALIAN
LAW. BUT THEY TURN EIGHTEEN IN
THIS AUTOMATIC BEYOND THE ROLES
FIFTY DON'T CHOOSE TO UTILIZE
THEIR FRANCHISE MEANT THAT'S
FINE THAT'S UP TO THEM. BUT
RIGHT NOW NOT ONLY ARE WE
EXPERIENCING VOTER SUPPRESSION.
WE'RE ALSO SEEING DROPS IN
REGISTRATION ACROSS THE COUNTRY
IN HERE IN CALIFORNIA BECAUSE
WE MAKE IT NOT ONLY HARD TO
VOTE WE MAKE IT HARD TO
REGISTER AND IT'S WRONG AND WE
SHOULD ELIMINATE EVERY CALL
CORRECT THREE IN PUTTING I
STAND STRONG SUPPORTER. SENATOR
BATES. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT JUST A CLARIFICATION
ON THE SEVENTEEN DAYS BECAUSE I
THINK WE'RE ALL THINKING
POSTMARKED AND PAY ATTENTION
TO- THE BILL ITSELF IT IS- SELF
CERTIFICATION YOU CAN SIGN IT
AND SAY THAT YOU'RE SIGNING UP
ON ELECTION DAY BEFORE OR BY
EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT
PM SO PAY ATTENTION WITHOUT
WHAT. AS WITH REGARDS SEVENTEEN
DAYS NOT RECEIVING IT ON. THE
TWO OR THREE DAYS AFTER
ELECTION IT CAN BE RECEIVED
FIFTEEN DAYS BECAUSE YOU SAID
YOU FILL THAT OUT FIFTEEN DAYS
BEFORE. IN A CENTER THERE DROP
IT OFF TO PAY ATTENTION TO THAT
THAT BOX THAT. IS IN A FRAT.
ALL OF THE CALM THAT ARE MADE
HERE TODAY THAT WE WANT IT ALL
TO BE HONEST AND YOU KNOW NO
VOTER SUPPRESSION ABSOLUTELY
NOT BUT DON'T GIVE AN
OPPORTUNITY LIKE THAT FOR THOSE
2% A YOU KNOW YOU AS A STANDARD
OF THOSE WHO DON'T FOLLOW THE
RULES TO UP IN AN ELECTION. A
CALL THE BARS IS RETURNING TO
THIS HOUSE. WHO WON A BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS SEAT BY THREE
VOTES. SOMEONE CAN SELF CERTIFY
WHEN THEY KNOW THAT THAT'S THE
MARK. AND GET THAT BALLOT IN
AND CHANGEABLE ELECTION. WE
NEED TO PAY ATTENTION TO IT. IN
THAT WE COULD MAKE THIS A
PERFECT A PERFECT BILL BUT THE
SEVENTEEN DAYS OF SELF
CERTIFICATION. CHALLENGE OUR
IT'S LEGITIMACY. THANK YOU.
THERE ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
AND DEBATE ON THIS ITEM.
SENATOR UMBERG YOU MAKE
CONCLUDE. THANK YOU COLLEAGUES
AND- MEMBERS LET ME SEE IF I
CAN ADDRESS SOME OF THE ISSUES
THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED AS TO THE
PENALTIES AYE I THANK SENATOR
HERTZBERG AND SENATOR JACKSON
FOR A SIGNATURE ISSUE. WHAT
WHAT COULD BE UP TO THREE YEARS
IN PRISON FOR VOTE FRAUD. OF
BOTH FRIES EXTREMELY RARE- I
ASSOCIATE MYSELF WITH SENATOR
HUESO COMMENTS THAT THE
CHALLENGE OF OUR TIME IS NOT
TOO MANY PEOPLE VOTING IT'S
FOLKS THAT. AREN'T AND- ARE
GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY TO VOTE
THE- I CAME PUBLIC OFFICE
BECAUSE EVENT THAT HAPPENED IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT OUR OWN
COUNTY OF ORANGE. WHERE THEY
WERE PEOPLE DRESSED AS POLICE
OFFICERS STANDING AT POLLING
PLACES IN LARGE LATINO AREAS
SANTA ANA. SIGN SAID NON
CITIZENS MAY NOT VOTE AND THEY
WERE ASKING FOR PROOF OF
CITIZENSHIP FOR WE COULD.
BELIEVE IT OR NOT NOT A LOT THE
TIME IT IS. HEY IF THE POINTS
OF THE- BOB. TEEN EIGHTY EIGHT.
PRESS A COUPLE OTHER ISSUES. IT
THE DOES FORCE DAYS AND FOR
EXAMPLE IF YOU'RE IN THE
MILITARY AND YOU DON'T HAVE A
POSTMARK AND YOU SIGN USE
CERTAIN YOU SENT IT YOU MAY
ELECTION DAY IT WILL BE CAP.
YES WITH RESPECT TO THE VOTE
COUNTED AFTER ELECTION DAY IS
REALLY A NON ISSUE IF THERE'S A
IF THERE'S A CLOSE ELECTION ONE
CAN TAKE A LOOK AND SEE ONE CAN
ACTUALLY. GO TO THAT INDIVIDUAL
VOTE OR IF THEY'VE NOT
CERTIFIED IT PROPERLY. UP THE
ISSUE CONCERNING SPEARS YES
THERE ARE CONSPIRACY THEORIES
OF CONSPIRACY THEORY
EXTRATERRESTRIALS WILL BE
VOTING IN THIS YEAR'S ELECTION.
THERE ARE NUMBER OF CONSPIRACY
SOME OF THEM. SOME FOLKS- HOT
IN IN OUR OUR FEDERAL. TURNS
COSTS YES. COST HERE BEEN S. BY
ON WHAT. THE REGISTRAR'S
BELIEVE WILL BE THE VOTER TURN
OUT IN NOVEMBER. NO SAYS WHAT
THE MORE COST THE DIVISIONAL
WILL BE THERE WILL BE SOME
MARGINAL COST THIS YEAR BUT
AGAIN THAT'S A VALUE STATEMENT
ON OUR PART IS TO WHAT WE VALUE
AND WHAT WE- BUDGET. SO SIT SO.
THAT IS EXACTLY WE'RE ABOUT IN
THIS IS SUCH BURDEN VALUE THAT
WE SHOULD APPROPRIATE
RESOURCES- IN TERMS OF. THE
ADDITIONAL OTHER COSTS- SOME
HAVE BEEN ALLOCATED BY THE
REGISTRAR OF VOTERS ALREADY BUT
THERE IS ALSOAN OPPORTUNITY
SHOULD. OUR ESTIMATES EXCEED
EVEN WHAT WE BELIEVE TO BE THE
DAY THAT THERE WILL BE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO PETITION THE
SECRETARY STATE FOR ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES ADDITIONAL. STRIKE
FORCE TO HELP PROVIDE THOSE
RESOURCES AND COUNTIES IT MAY
NOT BE ABLE TO QUOTE SO FOR
EXAMPLE IT MAY BE MORE
CHALLENGING TO GET. FOLKS TO
WORK THE THIS YEAR. DARKLY A
SENIOR CITIZEN THE POLLS AND IT
MAY REQUIRE US TO PROVIDE SOME
ADDITIONAL. GOVERNMENT
PERSONNEL TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN.
BUT ALL IN ALL OF THIS IS THAT
OF ALL OF THAT IN FRANCE DISS.
ALL IN ALL THIS IS A BILL THE
TEXT HELL. CALIFORNIANS ALSO
EMBRACES. TO VOTE I. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I ARCHULETA OR AYE ATKINS
I BATES. NO BELL I FORGES.
BRADFORD I CUT BY ADAM I CHIANG
I DALLY NO DODD. I THERE ARE SO.
I GALGIANI I GLAZER I GONZALEZ
I GROWTH NO HERTZBERG. I HILL I
LISTEN. I TADO. JACKSON I JONES
NO LEYVA I MCGUIRE I MELENDEZ
NO MITCHELL. I MONNING I MORE
LOCK. MORRELL NO NIELSEN. NO
HAN I PORTANTINO HI ROTH. I
RUBIO. I SKINNER. I STERN. I AM
VERY I WAY CASKEY I WIENER. I
WILK HI PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. FOR TADO. MORE LOCK HI.
FIVE THIRTY ONE ON THE URGENCY
ICE THIRTY ONE NO SEVEN ON ON
THE ITEM THE MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS THAT CONCLUDES OUR
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO OUR CONSENT
CALENDAR. WE PAY THEM. THROUGH
ONE ONE NOT. AND THE SPECIAL
CONSENT CALENDAR ITEMS ONE
TWENTY ONE THROUGH ONE THIRTY
EIGHT. MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL. 928-929-9313.
OH SEVEN ELEVEN EIGHTY ONE TEN
TWENTY NINE TWELVE EIGHTY FIVE
SENATE JOINT RESOLUTION FORTY
IN SENATE BILL. ELEVEN TWENTY
THREE SEVEN TWENTY SIX TWELVE.
HELLO 481-037-0513 OH FIVE. HE
WON I KNOW NINE FOURTEEN FIFTY
NINE. THE. NINETY FOUR EIGHT
HUNDRED EIGHT SIXTY FOUR EIGHT
SIXTY NINE NINE OH THREE NINE
EIGHT ONE
THIRTY ONE I SEE IT RIGHT
RESOLUTIONS. ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION. ONE
FIFTY THREE ONE FIFTY FIVE ONE
FIFTY FOUR ONE FIFTY NINE ONE
SIXTY FOUR SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION EIGHTY SENATE
RESOLUTION SEVENTY THREE SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION EIGHTY
TWO EIGHTY FOUR EIGHTY SEVEN
SENATE SOLUTIONS. SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION EIGHTY
EIGHT CENT RESOLUTION AND THIS
EIGHTY ONE EIGHTY TWO SAN BILL.
SEVENTY FOUR FOR THEN IN SENATE.
FIFTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN. IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION TO A PLAN THE
UNIT ROLL TO THESE BACK CONSENT
ITEMS. THING MAN ICE THIRTY
NINE DOES ZERO. THAT THE
CONTENT CALORIES CALENDAR IS
ADOPTED MOVING ON TO THE- ONE
MORE SPECIAL CONSENT CALENDAR
ITEM NUMBER ONE TWENTY. ON
PLEASE READ. SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION EIGHTY SIX. YEAH NO
IT'LL GET THEM IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO NO OKAY OKAY I
WILL TAKE A ROLL CALL ON THIS
ITEM. ALLEN I ARCHULETA OR AYE
ATKINS AYE BATES. BELL FIVE FOR
JUST I BRADFORD I HAVE I ADAM I
CHIANG I DALLY I DODD. HI THERE
I ASSUME I GALGIANI. I GLAZER I
GONZALEZ I GROWTH. HI HERTZBERG
BY HILL AYE HUESO. I TADA.
JACKSON I JONES. I LEYVA I
MCGUIRE AYE MELINDA'S. I
MITCHELL I MONEY I WANNA LOCK.
FIVE ZERO. I NIELSEN. I CAN I
PORTANTINO I ROTH I REVIEW. I
SKINNER. STERN I AM VERY HIGH I
LIKE HOW SKI. I WIENER. I WILK
HI PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS HE. EIGHT HI THERE YOU
GO. I THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO. THE
CONTENT IS SPECIAL CONSENT
CALENDAR IF IT IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS THAT COMPLETES THE
DAILY FILE ITEMS. THERE IS NO
OTHER BUSINESS SENATOR ATKINS
THE DESK IS CLEAR. THANK OU
VERY MUCH- MADAM PRESIDENT AND
TO MY COLLEAGUES LET ME JUST
SAY THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
TODAY AS WE HAVE HAD TO ADJUST
TO A NEW REALITY. I WANNA START
JUST ACKNOWLEDGIG THE FACT
THAT OUR OUR PRAYER AND OUR
INSPIRATION THANKS A WAS DONE
BY SISTER MICHELLE WHOSE
PRESENCE WE MISS BUT I
UNDERSTAND AND APPRECIATE HER
CAN YOU IN TO AND DOES. IN
STARTER SESSION DAY I WANT TO
LET YOU KNOW THAT I WOULD ALSO
TAKE- OUR SECRETARY OF THE
SENATE HER STAFF THE DESK STAFF
AND EVERYONE- BUT PARTICULARLY
ARE SO. THE BEAR THE
RESPONSIBILITY. TO ENSURE OUR
FOR ALL OF THE STAFF THAT WE'RE
RESPONSIBLE FOR AND FRANKLY TO
EACH OF US MEMBERS THAT WE
ADHERE TO THE PUBLIC SAFETY
GUIDELINES AND I UNDERSTAND
THAT NOT EVERYONE AGREES I
UNDERSTAND. THAT RESPONSIBILITY
AND EACH OF TWO ARE
INDIVIDUALLY AND I UNDERSTAND
PARTY IS WHEN WE SEE OTHER
PEOPLE ACTUALLY WHO SHOULD
FOLLOW THOSE GUIDELINES BUT WHO
ARE NOT. AND FOR THOSE THAT
INDULGE I IF THAT IS YOUR
PERSPECTIVE INDULGING OUR NEED
AND DESIRE TO DO THAT I JUST
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU. BECAUSE
IN THE LAST SEVEN DAYS- THROUGH
YESTERDAY WE LOST FOUR HUNDRED
SIXTEEN CALIFORNIANS TO THIS
AND IT IS SO EASY TO FORGET
THAT. AS WE GO AS WE DO THE
WORK THAT WE NEED TO DO AND HOW
IMPORTANT HIS WORK IS THAT EACH
OF YOU DO THIS DEBATE REFLECTS
THAT IMPORTANCE. AND I A I HAVE
TO SAY THAT EVEN AS IT GETS A
BIT OLD AND TIRING. TO HAVE TO
SPEAK THROUGH A MASK THAT EACH
OF US IS DOING A SMALL PART.
THAT CAN MAKE A DIFFERENCE AND
I HOPE YOU DON'T FORGET THAT
EVEN AS IT BECOMES DIFFICULT
AND- RETAINING AND- AND WE
REMIND ONE PERSON TO DO.
ANOTHER DIDN'T UNDER AND I MEAN
SISTER. I. N. I GREW UP WITH
THAT- I ALSO HAVE THIS X. BUT-
I JUST WANT TO BE MY- THANKS.
FOR MORE ALONG THESE LINES AND
THE RIGHT I'M SURE OF EACH OF
US HAD TO A PLAN FOR HOW BEST
TO DO EACH OF THESE THINGS
SAFELY WE WOULD ALL HAVE OUR
OWN VERSION OF WHAT THAT LOOKS
LIKE THROUGH THE LIST THAT WE
EACH HAVE DIFFERENTLY. BUT AS I
LOOK AT EACH OF MY COLLEAGUES
AND I PARTICULARLY. THANK ALL
OF YOU- FOR STEPPING UP AND FOR
BEING RESPONSIBLE AND THINKING
ABOUT OUR CONSTITUENTS AND I
WISH YOU- I KNOW THAT WE HAVE
BUDGET ACTIONS IN THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE TO BORROW THANK YOU
FOR THAT WE'RE DOING ALL
TRUMPCARE. AS WE HAVE WORKED.
HARD I- AND I WANT TO THANK
EACH OF YOU FOR THAT AND HAVE A
GOOD KID IF YOU TRAVEL. ALSO
ENJOY. IT IS SO TO SEE. YOU ARE
WE COULD BE UP CLOSE AND
PERSONAL AND I WOULD GIVE EACH
OF YOU I SAID EACH OF YOUR
VIRTUAL APPROPRIATELY GIVEN. I
BECAUSE I APPRECIATE EACH OF
YOU SO MUCH OF WITH THAT MAN
I'M- PRESIDENT WE WILL ADJOURN
ON MONDAY- WE WILL ADJOURN OR
BE IN RECESS EXCUSE ME WE WILL
BE IN. UNTIL MONDAY JUNE
FIFTEENTH AT ONE O'CLOCK
DIFFERENT TIME FOR US AS
EVERYTHING SEEMS TO BE ONE
O'CLOCK. SENATE PRESIDENT
THANK. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM PROGRAM- UNDER MOTIONS
AND LUCIEN'S WITHOUT OBJECTS.
AUTHORS AMENDMENTS REPORTED BY
THE BY DIDN'T WILL REVIEW
COMMITTEE. WILL BE ADOPTED HER
DAY AND SO. JUNE TEAM AND-
THIRTEEN AND FOURTEENTH TWENTY
TWENY. AND ALSO MEMBER IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO WISH A HAPPY
BIRTHDAY. TO HIM JOHNNY READING
CLERK. TEST TODAY. WORKED ON
DAYS. JOHNNY FOR THAT. THE
SENATE WILL BE IN TILL THIRTY
THIS AFTERNOON AT WHICH TIME
THE ENGER MOST WILL BE WE WILL
RECONVENE AS INDICATED MONDAY
AT ONE THANK YOU TO EVERYONE.